I guess it's not really uh it's not a real complaint for me because
I guess I'm not a victim or men can't be victims. Oh my god.
Is it like performance art when you say that you or or men in
general can't be victims while just immaculately victimizing
yourself to everybody? Is that performance art? I feel like it
should be.
There's a really well-connected New York law firm. They recommended
um Andrew and that law firm in California who's been exemplary
so far. They've been really good. Um not idea to pick the really
scummy lawyers. It was the other people's idea. He I had no agency
in this decision at all.
I literally I have spots. What am I supposed to do? Uh no, you're
an adult with self-control. I believe in your ability to do that.
That's the nicest thing Kelly has ever said to me. Oh my god.
You're an adult with self-control and I believe in you. You It's
either that or you want me to treat you like a child like Amaranth.
So I don't know.
Treat adults like adults until proven otherwise. Okay. So we
go back to before the weekend. I think this was when Destiny
was like acknowledging these things for the first time when he
was talking about them for the first time when these things got
filed. These uh I think it was the affidavit. So he talks he's
talking about it May 9th. We'll just read through some of the
chats here. Uh, Destiny, new court case memes. Parkchan, at some
point the memes have to go ahead and become dreams. These people
are just filing the most random/nonsense. Destiny, there is new
today. It's just all meme like filing declarations under seal
without even getting approval from the court as part of these
last minute motions or sorry getting approval from the court
as part of these last minute motions. And they haven't even made
the info available to us. It's just meme. Like they're literally
just ignoring emails from my lawyers. Like I could be wrong,
but I think she's just reading this wrong. And then there's this
picture posted. Hold on. What is the picture? Oh god, I don't
have the picture. I didn't grab the picture. Somebody Somebody
Hold on. I can actually do it. I can do it over here. Hold on.
1 C
SZ3.png. Image cannot be found. What? Hold on. Oh, CSZ. There
it is. Uh, so there's a picture of a ruling. Note that local
rule 5.4 4 B1 provides in relevant parts if prior to the issuance
of a ruling on the motion to file under seal. The moving party
elects or is required to publicly file a pleading motion, memorandum,
or other document that attaches or reveals the content of the
proposed sealed material. Then the moving party must redact from
the public filing all content that is subject to the motion under
seal to file under seal. Plaintiff elected to attach the declar
declarations to the reply and file simultaneously motion. Well,
no, no, no, no, no. Hold on. I think technically they would have
said we're filing this motion under seal and then we're filing
these things, right? And they are the moving party there. So
they should be able to say okay also we're going to file these
things with things redacted. Defendant has no right to receive
the unredacted documents at this time. Oh yeah, that's what they're
citing. It would also be highly negligent if we were to provide
to your client the unredacted documents without the protection
of their identities by the court in light of your client's recent
public statements over the weekend. Oh, this is talking about
So basically um uh this is referring to Hold on. Where is this?
Where is this here? It truly just took me 5 minutes to realize
why my sound sounded like I got my left and right ear about face
up. Oh, I see. So, when they talk about his conduct over the
weekend, I believe they mean this little log right here where
Destiny when the things first got filed when Destiny started
leaking things about Abby, right? They're like, "Hey, we actually
need a court motion to seal before we provide identities because
if you know the identities, you're probably going to do something
like talk this person publicly and talk about about them publicly.
So, we actually need to have this filed under seal so that you
don't feel comfortable like crashing out on them publicly." That
seems like a reasonable uh argument to make. No. If you if you
when you found out this person's identity, you immediately like
crashed out on them, then we we don't want we want actually this
to be filed under seal so that you'll have some sort of uh you
know there'll be there'll be consequences if you crash out again.
Talk about these people someone insane and unhinged to snoop
through someone's diary, take pictures, and send it to people.
What does it mean when you send your wife's therapy documents
to the woman you want to? It means that your outrage is totally
performative and you don't actually care about your wife's privacy
at all. It is just a performance for your chat so that they will
show you sympathy because you don't actually feel human emotion.
You're just pretending to. You are a lizard. But uh yeah, we
haven't gotten there yet. Kelly, stop
You just had it up on the stream. Uh it's uh Okay, that's my
bad. But um I don't have it up. The the thing comes later, but
it's okay. It really does. It's like actually not a big deal.
So he hasn't talked about the what do you call it? The um that
the she's taking pictures of the diary yet. Yeah. And then I
believe Pixie's lawyer say moreover, so this is when Destiny's
Destiny's lawyer filed the uh counter motions is when he's commenting
on it. So this is the picture he posted. Moreover, you have the
full unredacted substantive content of the declarations. The
only redacted portions are those that would reveal the identities
of these declarants. There can be no legitimate urgency for you
or your client to know these witnesses legal identities. That
does not alter the facts or your ability to defend your client
in these proceedings. So basically, Destiny's arguing that Pacer
or whatever wherever the documents are be are being filed that
like essentially things shouldn't be allowed to be filed there
and be public because I'm guessing that's like he he feels like
it's harmful to his reputation when his actions come to light
to people, right? So basically he's saying that that shouldn't
be allowed there because under like rules of evidence we argue
that that shouldn't be allowed. You shouldn't be allowed to file
these things. It's unrelated to the case, right? But realistically
those rules are honestly very significantly like for a jury,
right? A jury shouldn't see those things because they're prejudicial.
But a judge can see those things. They can be filed through the
court and the the court can go, "Okay, actually we don't think
this should be used or something." Right? That's that's what's
happening here. And he doesn't like that the things are being
filed. But he's done the same thing. He's included things that
are arguably like totally unrelated. and he's filed them publicly
and he hasn't asked and he hasn't like done anything to prevent
you know bad bad outcomes so it seems like that's the way going
down feels kind of weird but um and I I actually don't agree
necessarily that everything here is is unrelated but anyway keep
reading his logs is there uh so he said these people are just
filing the most random/nonsense this is kind of goofy in that
like the filing that was made was actually quite critical saying
hey this establishes that you violated Cardi because it happens
within the bounds of Cardi being enacted. Destiny, there's new
today. It's just all meme like filing declarations under seal
without even getting approval from the court as part of these
lastinute motions. So I believe so I didn't think I didn't think
you could file these things, right? But I I got corrected by
esports Batman. It seems like as long as you file under you say
here's what here's what we want to seal. Here's our reasoning
and then you file them under seal, you should be able to get
a judge to approve them for you. and you have like legal arguments
and they really aren't doing something that's sanctionable, right?
Like they're they're they have arguments for they have a a legitimate
argument for everything they're doing. The judge may rule against
them. She may say, "Actually, if you don't want to give these
identities over or actually it's not valid for these things to
be under seal, but the judge isn't going to I don't believe the
judge will go like, "Oh, we need to sanction you guys because
you're acting completely inappropriately." I don't believe so.
Could be wrong. Not a lawyer. In any case, just because I haven't
been here last few days. Uh what day is this from? So, where
are we starting from? Is this like This is May 9th. This is late
May 9th, early May 10th. So, the morning of May 10th. It's like
four or five days ago. Okay. Yep. Yep. That's where these logs
are from. Okay. Okay. So, uh it's just all meme like filing declarations
under seal without even getting approval from the court as part
of these last minute motions. And they haven't even made the
info available to us. It's just meme. Like they're literally
just ignoring emails from my lawyers. Like I could be just wrong.
Uh I could be wrong, but I think she's just reading this wrong.
Uh I think basically almost almost certainly they are okay within
the the rules here. There might be an argument that they need
to share this with the other side. But I do think they have reason
to believe like hey we want to wait before sharing it. And I
don't think Destiny side has any argument that they need to that
it's like absolutely imperative that they answer within a day
or two before the judge can look at it. Like the judge should
be able to look at it and say okay I don't think or I think this
should be able to be filed under seal. I don't see any like uh
I don't see that he needs to have it right now. like the identity.
Sorry. Like he's arguing that um is this all just priming? I
think it's mostly just priming the cult. Yes. So they feel bad
for him. They feel like he's under attack and they will defend
him without actually considering what what's going on. Uh the
local rule she's citing is saying they can't file anything under
seal that hasn't been approved by the court. If they file it,
they have to redact everything that's the subject of the motion
until it's approved. Right. No, they have to they have to the
motion to uh seal is not sealing the entirety of the affidavit.
It's sealing just the identities of the people. That's that's
the issue that I he might not understand. But they haven't but
they didn't do that. They just filed the motion with their own
redactions and haven't made anything available to us or gotten
court approval from the court. They're just spamming the document
with actual And then there's this picture which I think we just
pulled up. Why does she think she can determine this on her own
without the Oh, yeah. This is the one. This is this one right
here. Giving your client's court. So basically they're saying,
you know, your client has been blast blasting people in public.
We don't want to file the identities so that they are protected
and then we don't want to let him know because if he doesn't
know, it's going to protect them until you can actually file
this motion to put these identities under seal. Once they're
officially under seal, we'll give the identities to the defense.
Does he think subject means content and not subject as in a person?
Uh, wait. I think Wait, you might be right there, Sya, that it
means that, but I don't. I I took it as subject uh under under
the motion as in everything that's the subject of the motion
until it's approved. So I thought the subject of the motion was
going to be they have to redact everything that's the subject.
I think it's I think subject there means what the motion is about.
I think I think it means subject as in but the motion to seal
I believe is just about identities is how I've interpreted it
so far. Uh Destiny yes they had to redact all of it. It seems
this person I don't believe so Artur but they didn't redact it.
All of those declarations are public just waiting for the magistrate
judge to rule in the PI. There's a non-zero chance that the case
can be tossed there but we'll see. Um, I don't understand why
a magistrate judge would be able to toss the case. That doesn't
make any sense. The the presiding judge over the whole case is
literally has already literally set a court date. I don't understand
why this magistrate judge would be able to toss the case, but
okay. Toss the PI maybe. Destiny, do you have a court date? Top
thrills sometime next year. Good guy. Creeper says, "Destiny,
is there a point where you could counters suit for defamation
because you and the Jane do know YouTubers will talk about it
and it would affect your reputation and cause you financial harm?"
Good guy. Creeper, you can't accuse people of defamation for
what they put in a lawsuit. I believe obviously. Thank you. Uh,
Manly Han Destiny, the first rule sounds like it's the reason
they can redact stuff prior to a ruling on the ruling motion.
Uh, prior to a ruling on the ruling on a motion to file under
seal. If they haven't motioned to file under seal yet, it's kind
of just a minor procedural error. Oh yeah, but they did motion
to file under seal. Now, Destiny doesn't like that they motioned
to file under seal at the same time that they submitted everything,
right? But there is a timeline there. There's a time pressure
and that is one of the allowances of the local rules. It says
if there is a timeline, if there's a time pressure, you can motion
to file under seal and then under that motion file things redacted
gather. So the issue the issue here is is basically these things
can be filed. It can be an affidavit that's on the record and
their identity can be protected and then the judge can say whether
or not it's filed under seal um if it's not filed under and the
judge would probably decide hey these identities could be given
over so Destiny could attach identities after the fact if it's
not filed under seal right there's just the so it's basically
a trade-off between okay if you if you couldn't do this then
do you just not get to file evidence that you find um maybe late
do you not get to file that if if there's a safety concern so
it's balancing basically um I guess the the defendant's you know
right to fair procedure or whatever against the downside of the
plaintiff not being able to um to file things like correctly
and there really isn't very much downside against the defendant
like realistically he will probably get told these identities.
It's just the judge, the the lawyers on the other side are saying,
"We don't want to tell you who the who the people are until we
know that things are going to be under seal because we think
if you know them and there's an official order for this to be
under seal, you'll probably talk about these people. So, we're
going to wait." Now, that might be against procedure. They might
have to tell Destiny's legal team who those identities are. I
don't know, but I think the filings are mostly kosher is my understanding
so far. So, uh, Gather, what's up with you posting in like Destiny's
kick chat like, uh, at Destiny every minute per hour, and I saw
you in there the other day. You're right, buddy. Uh, so my reading
is that you have to that redact the entire motion until the court
rules on it being sealed or not. And then Manly Han says all
content subject to the motion to file under seal. Sounds like
specific portions that they want to seal from the public record.
Manly on. It's not content subject to the motion that is going
to have it's not content subject to the motion that is going
to have sealed info. I don't think so. On page 20, doesn't underceal
just mean it's not public? They still have to give you and your
lawyers or am I tripping? I think the issue is they want the
ruling on on it being sealed saying, "Hey, you're not allowed
to discuss this?" They're concerned. Yes, they do. Uh, we should
look at this. But I I So Esports Batman took a look at this and
I'm just basically repeating the information he gave me about
uh how the procedure works. I think it's uh it might be debatable.
We'll see. We'll see how it goes. Okay. Uh yes, they do. They
haven't. They're just making up rules. So this might be true.
It might be true that they do need to say this and they're saying,
"Well, we don't trust you because you guys have been basically
leaking a whole bunch of stuff in conference, right? Destiny's
team has not been, in my opinion, acting in good faith. They've
leaked um they've leaked leaked Pixie's initial demand. They
leaked the negotiations over the original preliminary injunction,
right? So, they were negotiating like and Pixie, I think, offered
to like take down her Substack or something in exchange for Destiny
taking down his videos and all of her DMs. Like, I think that
was an offer that was made or something. And Destiny leaks all
of those offers even though they're not agreed to. Yes. So, so
he's leaked that he's leaked that stuff. Uh, he's leaked the
the initial offer and then he started talking about Abby before
the filings were made on Abby, right? Or after the filings were
made about Abby. And it's like, well, you know, one of these
people's identities, and you immediately start a character assassinating
them publicly on one of your big platforms, so we don't want
to tell you the identities of the other people until we actually
know that you'll shut the up. I think that's totally reasonable.
How is that interpreted? Like, I don't know. And so, if if one
pe one side of things is like seemingly good faith and they're
trying to negotiate and then the other side is like you guys
and then leaks all of the negotiations, the be seen as like a
negative in some way. I don't know if it's penalized or not.
I just They need that to a judge and I have seen no filings that
demonstrate that to a judge yet. They have to demonstrate that
to a judge. Like why do that? Isn't that just a negative to you
and not to no benefit? I don't What is the point? I don't know.
I I don't know. Um it might be that you can I think it's just
against like normal normal procedure. Like I think it's against
norms basically. Why didn't they just wait until the seal was
granted then? Uh because there was a deadline vigilance stream.
They literally just got in under the deadline. They were like
literally having issues filing right at the deadline. So why
didn't they just file wait until the seal was granted if they
were too worried about giving the identities to Destiny? They
clearly have an obligation to disclose to the defense the identities
of the people see. Yeah. Yeah. I I agree with you. I believe
it's that they were on a deadline and I believe there are special
allowances made on a deadline and they will have to disclose
those and they've said they will disclose them once it's officially
under seal. So I don't know. So federal rules of civil procedure
26. Let's see. Duty to disclose. So again, let's see where if
you want to highlight a a section I can go to to see how this
is handled under seal, I can do that. But yeah, you you can you
can highlight a section for me if you like. Anyway, we continue.
Where were we here? They haven't given anything to us. Give you
and your lawyers the identities. They haven't given anything
to us. They're just making up rules. They said they would provide
us, but they haven't. And now they're like, uh, actually, um,
we don't have to. To be clear, because of your client's statements
related to Jane Doe and any potential witnesses, we had to file
these under seal. Once the court rules on the motion, we will
proceed accordingly. If the court grants the motion, you will
know their identities. Thank you. Like, wait, what? So, they're
saying if the court denies their motion, they will just withdraw
the declarations without ever providing us unredacted copies.
So, I think basically the court could absolutely order this,
right? The court will just decide what is correct. Like, there's
no downside to Destiny here. He thinks, oh, they could pull back
without giving the identities. If Destiny should have gotten
the identities, the court will just order them to be given, right?
So I don't know why he's like spuring the out over this if if
he should have had the identities in the f first place and that's
important. The court will just say actually you have to provide
those unredacted copies to this person. There's no time pressure
on Destiny's side. There was a time pressure on Pixie side. So
I don't see I don't see where the rush is on any of this. The
end of the day regardless of the section/ rules this minutia
still lies in the judge's hands. The judge has already sniped
at the plaintiff. Hopefully the judge doesn't further see the
flowery language as a negative. Well, hold on. For for this one
explicitly, it says in the I believe the local rules that none
of the procedure around this could possibly reflect badly on
Pixie or her case. The only thing it could reflect negatively
on is Pixie's lawyers. That's it. So, proposed sealed material
is any information or documents you want sealed according to
the local rules. So, that that would mean just the identities.
Yeah. Here, I can pull up the picture here. One second. If prior
to the issuance issuance of a ruling on the motion to file under
seal the moving party elects or is required to publicly file
a pleading motion memorandum or other document that attaches
or reveals the content of the proposed sealed material. So the
sealed material's identities then the moving party must redact
from the public filing all content that is subject to the motion
to file under seal. So they they must they're literally because
they filed a motion to seal they are actually compelled to redact
these in the public filings. Okay. Now, I do think that they
probably have a duty to provide the unredacted copies to the
defense. Is there a time pressure on that? I don't know what
the time pressure on that is. That the idea that the defense
says, well, there's a time pressure that you have to like you
literally have to provide it to us um as it's filed or whatever.
I don't know if that's real. We'll see. We'll see what the judge
says. It's again ultimately, yeah, it's in the judge's hands.
Okay. So, why would the admission of a seal change the substance
of the case? Omegaol, it doesn't. Actually, this is this is a
question that actually um that actually Destiny's position. Yeah.
Why would the emission of a seal the the argument from their
side is saying, "Hey, actually, you you can literally argue against
the substance like the the declaration being filed like you can
argue against the substance. You have everything you need to
to defend yourself, right? Here's the allegation being made against
you. You do have a right to face your accuser." Now, the time
pressure on that is again unknown. Uh I don't think you can just
have random anonymous people filing anonymously redacted with
the court. Uh, you can if it's under a time pressure and it will
go in front of a judge and the judge will decide if it was if
it was done in good faith or not. Is it true that Pixie's lawyers
don't even work in in this field of law? The way he explains
it seems pretty inexperienced, but that could just be him ranting.
Uh, so we'll get to that in the videos. I think Pixie has a lawyer
that is that is from Puerto Rico that normally does like immigration
law. I think that's uh the the Joan person, but it doesn't seem
like she's the person filing most of the paperwork. So, that
seems like a red herring, right? Like the person filing most
of the paperwork and signing it is the person from the the Coral
Gables law firm that Pixie hired. And the Joan Peters person,
the Jones Peters person is somebody from Puerto Rico. But I don't
they're not filing most of the paperwork. So I don't know I don't
know where that's coming from that like oh the filings are because
this person doesn't know the law. They're not filing most of
the paperwork. I don't know. Uh so stareyed wonderer. I don't
think you can just have random anonymous people filing anonymously
redacted with the courts just to see what sticks. So the the
allegations are being made like automatically and then the motion
to seal is being filed. I I don't know how it works. It's possible
if the motion to seal isn't granted that those copies just stay
actually filed with the court and they just go public unredacted.
Like that's what the judge orders you have to file those publicly
unredacted. That's possible. Respond to anything with substance.
Uh does it even matter if it's not accepted? What's up? Look
up. I mean if it's not accepted they could just withdraw the
declarations for free. That's stupid. Again none of this. So
they're basically saying this is the evidence that should go
in. And realistically what Dusty is what what a whole bunch of
these rules of evidence are about is about how things are. Some
of them are about wasting time and some of this stuff is about
wasting time. So I'm not going to say that's impossible, but
a lot of it is about what goes in front of a jury. And the judge
can just rule on these things. He's creating a time pressure
here. He's acting like they're litigating the case already. They're
realistically just filing motions and they're saying how the
CA how the evidence of the case should be like landscaped. Um
it's I don't know. It's kind of goofy that he's pretending that
like this has all been like super evil when the judge can just
like with a pen make it all go away. Yeah. I don't think it would
really make any sense to to publicly submit unsealed documentation
to request for it to be sealed because the point is to not have
the unredacted material shown. Yeah, exactly. Uh and by the way,
this is what Molina and NMP did. They filed their unredacted
and and asked for it to be sealed at the same time. It was unsealed
for like 10 hours and Henry Resilient grabbed it and read the
whole document on his stream. Right. And that's what they wanted
to avoid here was people grabbing this because of the public
interest in the case, grabbing the documents and reading them
on a stream like me. So waiting for the judge to finally make
another ruling on what's being submitted so far because holy
destiny sus. I wonder what they have on you that they would go
to such lengths to keep you from seeing what they have. That
that that's not happening. This person literally is just this
person is just emotionally reacting to what Destiny said. And
it's like Destiny, you must be getting, man. I can't believe
what they what they think they have on you that they're hiding
all this. No, they're literally just hiding the identities. The
allegations are all out there. This person is just the most is
the bottom of the barrel suck. Okay, this is sad. This is a sad
comment from a sad person. So, nothing. Have you he reply to
people that don't fit that description lately? I don't know.
Uh, that's all that's left. Seems to be the case. Good guy creeper.
That suck is dick literally and metaphorically. Yes, Destiny.
In regards to stareyed wanderer, I don't think you can just have
random anonymous people filing anonymously. I think you should
talk to your lawyer because random lawsuits feels like it should
be open to defamation and if not perjury. So this is the thing
is if these things weren't being done in good faith like they're
affidavit they're filing, right? If it's perjury, yes, they're
affidavit that are open to penalties for perjury. That's on the
people who are filing those. The there's no reason to suspect
the lawyer is doing something wrong here. They're literally affidavit.
Yes, if these people are lying or just making things up, they
are subject to laws against perjury. Okay, good guy creeper.
You have no idea. Want waiting to talk more about the that until
4 weeks has passed though. It's Jover. Destiny's lawyer misspoke.
He did misspeak. No, you're specifically asking for filings without
emoji reactions. Idiot. Why, Destiny? Why four weeks then? I
mean, the issue is the case was technically dead until they brought
in a new person under sealed to testify about receiving some
video from me. But that person hasn't provided any evidence whatsoever
for this actually hap that this actually happened. No witness
testimony is evidence. And they're literally saying they don't
have the files. They literally say in there, "Hey, he sent me
this file. I described it to other people. I said to other people
that I thought it was this file or whatever." Right? That's what
she says and it's her word. Um, so I don't know why he's saying
this. She literally says she doesn't have the video. I don't
know what we're expecting here. So, and the case was technically
dead. He he does this whole thing where he pretends it's like
last minute. Dude, one, people can amend the original complaint
for like a very long time. You are a year away from trial. This
is not crazy. It's not weird. It's not strange. Uh, also there
was a filing that was made that said, "We believe these people
could have information." And as far as we know, Abby is one of
the people on there. He's talking about the ABMC declaration,
right? The ABMC person was listed by by that pseudonym in the
declaration of people who could have evidence. So, it's not like
they were totally unknown to the case or something, right? Doesn't
seem last minute random. Oh, also the the when he talks about
how it's random, that's very funny. It's like, no, this person
is literally saying that you she they're literally saying you
committed this exact thing. You did this exact thing. Couldn't
be any less random. It's totally pertinent to this case. Anyway,
Destiny, I would think in a perfect world, the judges would just
throw out the cases if this type of behavior happens because
the courts can can can't can't just accept the rules from any
party. Um, they can literally just say this evidence doesn't
go before a jury. Yeah. Yeah. I'm hoping there are sanctions
or something for the lawyers on the other side. The behavior
has been ridiculous. It's been ridiculous. Okay, so that was
before his uh his videos came out. Okay, we're going to move
on. We're moving on to the videos. Moving on. Moving on. Okay.
Uh yeah, I think we're on to the Riyle videos, which I didn't
grab. I'll just go to the YouTube channel and grab them now.
So, this was all a prelude to the videos he did a couple days
ago where he covered this on stream again. I think Riyle published
some stuff here that we can cover with like dead air removed
and in these logs. Sorry. Does it have the comment or is that
later when he mentions you? He mentioned you like last few days,
wasn't it? I believe that's later. I believe that's my own. Yeah,
I it should be in these videos somewhere, I think. Oh, no. Those
logs are those logs will be after these videos, Kelly. Yeah,
like quite a bit after these videos. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Are
we going to see the litter box bit? Oh, I don't know. Wait, does
did he say loader box at some point?
Why not? He said I didn't see that. I didn't know he said that.
That's [__] up, dude. We love loner box here. The
hell? I saw her box awesome. Destiny a rapacious fest. And I'm
like, how do you say rapacious? Like that's how I'm saying it.
It's not a real word. So that's how I decided to say it. It's
quite a good word, isn't it? Rapacious. Someone that reviles
in, but like it's delicious. It's just a funny word combination.
It is
or it is goofy. I said rapacious is a good one. LB acted. still
for his benefit and he's still [__] on him. No, I
think Lonerbox sees this as his job and he doesn't think it's
appropriate to vend his private feelings at his job that much.
Uh, anytime Lonerbox has spoken on this has been unequivocal.
Destiny's a piece of Destiny. He's never been like he's never
fallen off of that or like been like, oh, you know, well, actually,
there was a point where like early on he was like, I don't know
if Destiny's that bad. But I think that was before he even went
public. Okay, my bad. I thought he was just making a trying to
call him without saying Oh, you didn't know. Oh, I could have
said that. Rapacious. Yes, rapacious. That's funny. I'm trying
to see if I missed any. I thought there was a message here. Somebody
was like quoting something. A finger filing redacted exhibit
must contemporaneously serve a version of the exhibit upon all
council and prosay parties that is either unredacted or contains
only the those redactions authorized in connection with the producing
a document in to another party in discovery. So I don't know
what there are and I don't know if that would fall under local
rules. I do believe they'll have to give it over vigilance stream.
I just don't know that there is a like an immediate time pressure
on this. And if that is the case, if that is the case that they
had to produce it simultaneously and it was up that they didn't
do it, the judge will just say you have to give them the identities,
right? So again, there's just no real like concern that this
is happening. The the the idea that like Destiny's being harmed
by this happening is totally wrong, right? It's sorry, it's to
that he he's harmed by it and it's like unreoverable is totally
wrong. And it's mostly rooted in the idea that like this testimony,
you know, gives the case legs in a way it didn't have before
that he he needs to diminish it. But if there was something wrong
here, if there was something happened, if something happened
here where where Destiny was wronged, it will be easily fixed
within like a week or two. This is no problem. Let's say the
redaction does go through on the filings. If you were to sh talk
to them in public, how much would he of that would be used in
court? Well, I think basically anytime he is talking to a witness
or to a victim or to somebody who's like related to the case,
I think all of those will probably be used. We've seen some evidence
that the the in their conferences in their meet and cverse that
they're already bringing up his conduct, right? Like this conduct
specifically. So, we'll see. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I don't doubt
that Destiny does have a right to see those identities, but I
think um they're concerned about giving those over without uh
without basically a court order protecting those people because
of how he's acted so far. I just realized like I looked up rapacious
and there's so many words that are based on I've never heard
of in my life like repine a violent seizure of someone's propert
what words. Sorry, I was just curious. Uh he claims to want to
demand discovery on those people attempting to prove collusion
or hypocrisy.
Uh why would hypocrisy matter for one? But even if he wants to
demand discovery, he could just do that once. Like literally,
if he has a right to have those things, the judge will just order
it given over to him and he can do that. There's literally no
problem here whatsoever. The idea that like there's something
done here that's like requires people disbarred, that's like
ludicrously delusional. But
uh pensive goat, we will once we get to Aby's DMs, we talk about
that. I'm chastised for because everything about it was stupid.
Can you explain to people that say it's unreasonable for you
to request the legal identity of the person because you most
likely know who it is anyway? Yeah, we're going to get to that
because I'm going to start to I'm It's not unreasonable. It's
just when you pretend like you can't defend yourself because
you don't know who the people are when you've already been talking
about the people, it rings a little hollow like you just sound
like a liar. It's not It's not that uh it's not that you know
or sorry, it's not that you don't know. It's that you you want
like basically that to be filed to your lawyer. It's it's fine,
but like you you know you know who they are. You're you're like
just trying to make hay out of whatever you can. Like it's just
obviously you're just obviously lying which you're treating everybody
like the rest of us don't like being treated like I understand
DJs do but want to make some allegations here cuz all of this
I don't think people realize how absolutely ridiculous all of
this [__] is and I don't know if it's being driven
by like a lawyer who should be sanctioned or if the other like
plaintiff is actually like encouraging like illegal behavior
or what. I'm not sure but whatever. Why would So this law this
law firm is like a five partner law firm where Pixie has like
not even one of the partnered lawyers at it. It's a huge law
firm with like a reputation in that area. Why can somebody explain
to me why they would like risk their law firm for Pixie for Pixie
who doesn't have that much money? Is there some I don't like
this is we as we get through this it'll become clear that that
Destiny is sorry I said name partner vigilant stream. I know
you don't understand. It's fine. Don't worry. Um, it becomes
very clear that he starts building like a conspiracy in his head
that's not really supported by anything and doesn't make any
sense like at all. Like it it's basically just a narrative and
it's like it sound he starts to sound like a Trump supporter
who's like trying to explain why Trump is not responsible for
January 6th. Like he just starts engaging in the weirdest conspira
like conspiratorial thinking. We'll see it. It's he's very weird.
Okay, hold on. Let me download some of these. buy these documents
that I have in my email inbox. Yes, usually when you file some
of these things like you have like a 10page limit and they filed
so they filed to have like an extension or an increase. They
have so much important stuff working totally fine but I can't
hear any sound. Oh, I have the audio shut off, don't I? Whoops.
Wait, how are you hearing anything? Profiling their support for
their No, you hear it now, right? Yeah. Yeah, I had um I had
the Discord audio shut off. I I was reverbing on myself earlier.
They had so much important stuff to say when they were filing
their support for their preliminary injunction. And all Destiny,
it's Chase Talk. Dude is obsessed with you. I see why this is
happening. There are people scoping him in his own chat. This
guy, I know exactly who you are, Mr. Mr. Fellow. I know exactly
who you are trying to sigh up this guy. That's [__]
up. All of it was just all like the random crazy [__]
that they say. Hold on. What was this? Was it this one? Can we
say anything that crazy? All I've done is called him fat and
cheap. Is that really like crazy? That's not that crazy. Declaration.
Was it this? Hold on. I guess I can show this cuz it's all public
anyway. How do you feel every single one of your friends besides
Dan dishing you out on something? So, listen. It's online. What
are you going to do? It's okay though. You find out who the real
ones are. You find out who the real the real brothers are. Okay.
Not this. And I think the real leeches. They'll leech through
anything leech. It is funny that like all Oh no, you just cut
out now.
Sorry. Should be back. Am I back? Am I back? What's going on?
I tapped my microphone and it cut out. Okay, so all these people
I don't know when you touch it slightly.
Okay, I'm going to talk real quick. So all of these people he
built up as authorities in his community like uh like Loner Box,
like uh like oh Josiah, like Pisco, like Supreme, like uh even
our relevant. He built all these people up as authorities. He
had all these people over to his house for his election stream.
Okay? And every single one of those people that he said are he
likes because they make good decisions. They make good arguments.
Every single one of those people walked away from him. And then
his cope is, well, I guess you see who the real ones are. Like
I I don't know what he's saying. The realest friends are the
ones financially incentivized to hang out with you. Yeah. Essentially.
Or people who are like so so cultlike in their devotion to you
like Darius, right? Darius is financially incentivized, but it's
like the cult like devotion is really what it is. He is also
an incredibly stupid.
But I just I would love anybody who who like is a part of DG
explain to me why all of these people that he lauded for their
ability to make arguments, their ability to make good decisions,
why every single one of those people walked. I don't I don't
know how he makes any sense of that. Why make sense when you
can just cope? This is what we I think we just filed this yesterday.
Um, wait. Where's the notice submitting amended certificate?
Wrong event. Wrong event. Wrong event. Nice. Okay. If you win
the case, what would be the consequences for her, which you have
to reimburse some of your legal fees? Um, I don't know. We'll
see. Where? Explicitly under the local rules for all of this
stuff. The seal stuff that is all like legal the all they would
all be um sanctions placed on the lawyers. They wouldn't be sanctions
placed on Pixie. They don't affect the case. Where is the uh
I'm just trying to find the where their 20page filing for prelimation.
Oh, was this plaint support a motion? Okay. Yes. Federal court
system have my money. Yes, I will support the government. The
things that most of the people disavowed him for masturbator
like the like the non-consensual sending of sexual uh picture
of pornographic videos, all that stuff, non-consentual record,
all of that, the non-consensual recording, all of that stuff.
I believe he hasn't even denied um the the recordings existing.
Like he he's he's like basically not denied any of it. He hasn't
come out and said this is false. is all like made up, right?
And for the Pixie stuff, he's literally signed an affidavit saying,
"I did that." So like the things he's been disavowed for, he's
just admitted happened. So I I don't even know where where we're
going after that. Like that like he acts like, "Oh, if I if this
is thrown out in summary judgment, like everybody will come back."
I think like the weird behaviors are those are probably just
things that people want to stay away from anyway, especially
if they have some successful platform of their own. Sorry. You
want to add to that? I thought you wanted to add to that maybe,
Kelly. Oh, no. No, you're good. It's fine. Okay. What? Government.
No, it's not this. This is the motion for the increase in page
limit. Okay. This is the response. This is a long one. No, this
is not it. Holy [__] Filed by this is me. My Hold
on. I am. Okay. What did you lick me? Response and No, no, it's
not. I'm not looking for our response. I'm looking for Okay.
This is ours. Okay. Okay. This is our big reply to their preliminary
injunction request. The preliminary injection that they're seeking
is ridiculous because they're trying to enjoin me from behavior
that they have no proof that I'm engaged in. I'm not even really
being accused of being engaged in it. Kind of. Um the Well, no,
no, no. The first and primary thing is please stop leaking Pixie
like DMs, messages, and stuff. Additional private details. That's
the first one. And you are engaging in that. You've continued
to engage in that. Um but go ahead and make things up, I guess.
And everybody knows that I'm not engaged in it. So like the big
things that they're looking to enjoin are things like um the
current distribution of this video on certain websites that I
have no control over but they're trying to join me from doing
it. So uh I believe they're trying to enjoin you as in they are
trying to compel you to actually fight that the things are maintained
on those sites like to send take down requests and stuff. So
it's not saying we think you're responsible for this site be
existing and you should need to take it down. It's saying hey
we want you to make legal requests for these things to be taken
down. You can't even represent it honestly. Go ahead, Kelly.
I think the grossest part about him leaking like pixies is that
his only purpose for doing it is trying to make her seem like
less of an inexperienced partner and more into the category [__]
We can dehumanize her now. Which is funny because that's something
that he got very mad at me for doing to his girlfriend and has
always been quite negative about in general. But he's okay. No,
when Yeah. He does it is it's fine. I think you'll find Kelly
that a lot of the behaviors Destiny criticized you for he engages
in very frequently. There's a lot of Yeah. I just think it's
very important to point out just so everyone else sees what a
piece of he is. Yep. We had our big response to that and then
they filed.
Sorry. Pixie is obviously not a right. he can. But that's what
his intent is is to is to try and put her in a category that
is uh less innocent so that he can like dehumanize her and get
away with it and that his audience would join in with it because
she isn't like she doesn't do only fans. She doesn't do something
that's like obvious on the surface level or something he could
get away with doing that without like character assassinating
her first and leaking stuff. Yep. Yeah, exactly. I read this
one on stream. I'm basically I'm looking for the last thing I
read on stream. Okay. Is it? Okay, [__] it. Let's
just Thank you. Jesus Christ. Okay, this was their Okay, this
was their big meme. Okay, so one thing to keep in mind is the
Okay, I'm restating some things that we've known. There are four
causes of action listed on the initial complaint. You have the
federal one that has to do with their cardi claims. What does
this stand for? I mean whatever it's civil something civil action
regarding intimate images I think regarding I think or I don't
know if art is regarding civil action intimate images the federal
statute that has regarding distribution of intimate images. Ah
let's go I think I got it with um sending material from one person
to another uh without consent of the person to transmit the material.
Nothing to do with revenge or recording. It's just like a transmission
basically to an individual as It doesn't have to be published
anywhere publicly, but it's a transmission from one person to
another basically when the person who was involved in making
the video didn't want that video to be transmitted to another
party to a third party. So the big issue with the big issue the
main issue with their case is that the the the main issue with
their case is that they are the only like evidence that they
have of any of this uh the transmission of this video taking
place to that rose person were before this law actually came
into effect which would mean that in the United States of America
laws don't take effect retroactively generally unless there's
like a special carve out in a congressional uh federal laws and
at any time those federal laws could be made retroactive I believe
I think those laws could be made retroactive in general. Um,
this is what happened to Trump in New York, right? Like I don't
think would Destiny argue that Trump was not held civily liable
for because they they actually like made the law so it went back
extra time. I I don't think so. Right. Statute or in some city,
you know, passing a law, you can't sue people for things that
weren't illegal at the time they did them. Generally, I think
it's I think it's irrelevant because I think like it's going
to be easy to prove that he continued this pattern of behavior
after the point anyway. just the the fact that he's coping so
hard that oh, they're never going to figure it out that I was
continuing to be a freak after the statue came into effect. It's
like, bro. So, regardless of the factual matter of whether or
not anybody was okay with anything being sent, um before even
getting to that, you would say that this case doesn't have a
leg to stand on because you have there's no evidence that that
actually happened when the alleged activity was illegal. So,
that was one of the things we called out in our response to their
preliminary injunction, basically saying like, "Hey, the complaint
is a fatal flaw. this federal statute that you're suing under
wasn't even in effect. So, this this whole case is meritless.
And if the federal claim gets shot down, the other three claims
are state claims, meaning that the whole case would be dismissed
from federal court and then they would have to refile with the
other three claims in state court. I would say I'm confident
that they wouldn't refile this because the other three claims
require like a lot more like malicious intent and stuff and it's
they're stupid. They shouldn't even be on this in the first place,
but whatever. I don't think they refile, but honestly, these
people might know. But there are ways to construct malicious
intent from what he did here. Um there there definitely are and
there's an argument to be made. I don't know if they go to state
court without the Cardi claim there because the Cardi claim does
like all of the elements outside of the time period for the Cardi
claim were already met. Now that the time period's there like
all the elements are met. It's like they absolutely can take
this through. So that's not wrong that the you know they could
also just file under something else. It's like um I looked at
the cuz somebody was asking about cases that civil cases and
how they are different like the McGregor case in Ireland was
more like charges like um it wasn't because it was a civil case
so it was all about sort of like personal damages and things
like that. I don't know what normally like prior to this statue
what women sued for but I assume it's something in that sort
of realm. I don't know. One of the lawyery people can sort of
say what more. It would be like a I don't know, but it' be like
dissemination of like materials that aren't necessarily like
Yeah. I don't know. Or some kind of emotional distress or something
like this, right? Yeah. I don't I have no idea. Okay. Something
like this. But they did still sue. The point is they did still
take action against similar cases as this and they still can
do they might file under something different, but he's coping
if they think they can't refile or something. Yeah. Sure. I'm
like unwinable. Like I would almost represent myself in those
except I'm not that arrogant but they're like really stupid claims.
So one of the frustrating things that they've done so in the
complaint there's two things that they All right. I'd almost
represent myself in those. I'm not that arrogant though. Okay.
Okay. Did that were a little bit annoying to me. The first thing
they did was they misrepresented a conversation between me and
that rose person by having the dates flipped to try So this is
the European dude. This is Is he really going? He's going to
go through from the top. Yes. Dates were flipped. Yes, bring
it in statute range. Some people say it's because some screenshots
don't the month and they were flipped. I would argue that it's
probably up to your due diligence to figure that out before you
file a [__] lawsuit. Um, in in the lawsuit there
is there is a part of the complaint that says we have somebody
who has stated to us that this was sent after the Cardi claim
date. So, Destiny's whole thing that this was filed under like
totally false means or totally a totally false pretense. Yeah,
they they said we have somebody we're working on like getting
testimony from them. But it is as a part of the complaint. There
is another person who alleged that the the video was sent in
November of 2024. Very easy to figure that out, but they didn't.
So, whatever. So, that was one issue. And then the second issue
is the um plaintiff brings up in the complaint, the plaintiff
brings up that a supporter messaged her and said that the supporter's
sister had been in contact with me and had received the video
in the complaint that the subject complaint two months ago, which
I I have no idea what that's in reference to. That's it's impossible,
but I'm like, okay, I don't know. It's interesting that you would
include that. One thing that I get very frustrated about is there's
a lot of like some people are pointing out that like oh Destiny
has good lawyers and they have bad lawyers and that's why you
know his side is growing better. That's not true. The issue so
far has nothing to do with good lawyers or bad lawyers. I see
like his side literally isn't doing better so far. I like this
is this is literally you you just literally you just are mind
and buy into Destiny's framing of like they're winning somehow.
Like Destiny's whole thing was they're so insane for filing a
TTRO. They're so crazy for doing all of this and the judge yelled
at them. Like the judge yelled at them because she was trying
to set the the the like the exact procedure in her courtroom.
She yelled at them. She was like, "Hey, make sure you confer
first." Right? That's what she did. But then she granted the
preliminary injunction healing uh hearing. She sent it to a magistrate
judge. She didn't say like, "Oh, everything you're asking for
here is insane." She's like, "I'll I'll pass this off to a magistrate
judge. Go ahead. Setting setting the court date for like a year
from now. It's literally none of it's insane." The idea that
like, oh, Pixie side's doing way worse. I don't I don't see that
anywhere. It's just like there's just none of that like bad or
bad I would say bad faith arguments or explicit lying or abuse
of the court system versus a side that is not trying to lie or
abuse the court system. So for instance when they file this complaint
initially there's absolutely no reason why they shouldn't sure
that's going to happen all of their affidavit all their declarations
in line that's very easy to have done prior to filing this complaint
sometimes sorry sometimes you can make the argument that like
the publicity this is presupposing that they knew this before
they filed the complaint I' I I see no evidence of that. Why
is he just he's just he's just making things up. He's just writing
his own head cannon and saying, "Well, they knew that this was
the case, so he should have filed it first." No, no. If a lawsuit
or something like that maybe would open up maybe something before
even discovery where somebody else would want to jump in and
file an affidavit, whatever, maybe. But all of those arguments
are completely destroyed due to the fact that plaintiff decided
to make a huge subsequently beforehand to maximize the amount
of attention that this entire ordeal will get. And she already
said in her complaint that there was a message from a supporter
who said that their sister had received something. Okay, so they
already had all this despite the fact that they laid this out.
That's weird that you don't see a vigilance stream because Destiny
literally just talked about it two seconds ago. So, there's two
huge issues that I have. Okay. One is that one issue is that
they made a bunch of claims in the complaint that they didn't
attach any evidence for like light evidence. I'm not saying to
like prove it, but there like there are no declarations. There
were no affidavit. There were no nothing. And then two, they
want to talk about or bring in so much stuff that's not a part
of this complaint. Nothing having to do with any other person
is relevant to the complaint that plaintiff has filed against
me. So, that is not necessarily true. there are arguments for
it, but I broadly think like um especially if it's not the same
conduct or if it's uh I I think there's probably been extraneous
information attached. And I said this, I I feel like both sides
are sort of using the filings as PR and we'll see if the judge
freaks out about that or what, but I I do believe both sides
are essentially including extraneous details to try to make the
other side look worse. I think that's probably broadly true despite
the fact that and I don't want to bring about names or anything
um because some people obviously have a lot of issues or whatever
going on but if you know you figure out like there's at least
one person who tweeted like several times like I don't know why
my name keeps getting brought up in this complaint I'm not a
part of this case I don't know why they keep bringing my stuff
up here I'm not a part of this for whatever reason just likes
to keep adding I I don't understand Destiny is like Destiny loves
to use um other people that he is wronged completely as like
evidence that they agree with him in some way when those people
don't agree with him they don't like him stop using them he does
this later on with Abby and Molina's journal. He pretends he
cares one iota about Molina's privacy when he's obviously violated
Molina's privacy dozens of times. He has sent around her like
private therapy document to a bunch of random people. Right now
he's talking about Cherry and I I think Cher Oh, I might have
just shut off my mic again. Oh, no I didn't. Not this time. Okay,
thank God. Okay. Um and I I can like understand Cherry doesn't
want to be attached to any other case because she just doesn't
want anything. She doesn't want she basically doesn't want anybody
like harassing her about stuff right now. I understand that and
I think it it's appropriate to respect that. Okay. She doesn't
want her name used because realistically there is no part of
this case where Cher's experience actually adds to the evidence
of this this case, right? It just doesn't. It's a different It's
a different thing. It's a different whole It's a whole different
thing. It actually doesn't add weight, I believe, to any part
of this at all. Maybe except for the the harassment stuff or
whatever when he's harassing like his victims or something. It
doesn't doesn't need to be added. Right. So, with regards to
Destiny, it's just to me I find it really performative and disgusting
when he's recorded Cherry without her consent. He's like violated
her consent horribly and now he's going to try to use her to
like prove that Pixie's bad. It's like, dude, you don't actually
care about this person. You don't. It's all performative. You
are so full of it's actually disgusting that you're gonna try
to use one of your victims to go ahead and like and try to make
another victim look bad. Like dude, oh god, I don't want to say
too much unhinged too early. Like yeah, it's understandable Cherry's
upset. Um but it's also understandable Pixie would use something
that is like public information at this point and reference it
and her thing, right? I I don't think it was unreasonable necessarily.
I think Well, I think it's unreasonable in that it doesn't do
anything for her case. It's like it's just probably going to
get cast away. But possibly I assume that was the lawyer's uh
decision, right? They have all this information and they decide
what to do with it. I doubt Pixie does. Adding a bunch of other
in here, which is not part of the complaint. You're not supposed
to do you're not supposed to do that because it's just it's extra
especially given the fact that they especially given the fact
that like literally asked for an extension on the page limit
here so that they could follow the 20page support of their motion
as opposed to the normal 10 page just so they can conclude a
bunch of other stupid. Okay, so sorry I'm now I'm venting. So
before I was kind of like just kind of covering the subject.
Oh, hold on. Donation donated $3. Slow it down to 1x. It's dead
air removed and ultra dense. It's like a Pink Floyd album. I
heard something new every time I listen. But I at this point
I feel like this is just bad behavior. Okay, so a few bad behaviors
is they keep bringing up Okay, warning for children listening.
Okay, careful. They keep bringing up evidence over and over again
that is not supporting the thing that they keep alleging. Okay,
Destiny, is it normal for court documents to be written so passive
aggressively? The other videos from his seemingly vast it's no.
It's amateur-ish, especially when you don't have the evidence
to backing it up. So, they keep referring to uh I don't know.
I I have no idea. I can't really I'm not the lawyer who evaluates
the length something. So, for instance, that Hannah girl that
tried to bait me on Discord into making statements, I guess,
that she immediately posted to just Discord server. They keep
citing this as examples of like, oh, he's still this is another
example of like conspiratorial thinking. And it's it's crazy
to me that instead of arguing why the evidence here is bad, I
would expect him to go to like the primary piece of evidence
and argue why it's bad. But instead, he has now made another
piece of evidence up or sorry, he's he's starting to argue like,
oh, and he's hinting at this, right? Well, it's crazy that she
asked me all these questions that she immediately went posted
the logs in Discord. It's like I don't I don't know how that
went down and I He keeps suggesting that like I had something
to do with it. No, I I didn't. The funny thing about the Hannah
thing was I didn't even post those logs. I literally People were
like, "Hey, you should talk about this." And I'm like, "No, I
don't. I don't know what's going on there. I have no idea. I'm
not touching that." Right? Like I That looked weird to me, right?
I mean, I thought this was the anti-Destiny stream/ Discord.
Is it not? Uh, well, we don't cover Destiny for most of the stream
content, so I feel like that's a weird way to define it. But
if you see it that way and that's what makes you want to sign
up and sub and gift money, then you can see it that way. Okay,
join the Patreon. patreon.com/gsd. We review all of Destiny's
content there. Every stream from every day, like 10 hours of
content every day. That's actually a lie. Please don't sub if
you think that's actually happening. Still offering to send uh,
you know, the video between him and Pix to other people. If you
read Hannah's own affidavit, I'm very explicitly and specifically
referring to videos of me performing oral on women. None of these
have to do with anything related to any video with Okay, I'll
just say it's already known that those are non-consensually distributed
videos of another person. We know that person. You're pointing
at vid. Just because you're not pointing at non-consensually
distributed of Pixie doesn't mean that that's a good act for
one thing. But then for a second thing, the place where you're
suggesting they go look at them. Okay. The place where you said
in your chat where they could go find those things, they're in
the same post with Pixie's video. You're literally pointing them
to the same post. Are you How dense are you? Why are you pretending
that you're not doing anything like this? Why are you pretending
that these are like totally un You're a [__] But
this is again, if you only watch Destiny's stream, you have no
idea of this context. uh he totally presents things presents
them completely disingenuously. I mean it's bordering on just
malicious lying. So and it didn't actually have to do with anything
related to the Kiwi Farms videos either. That was that was totally
unrelated. We've I think we've responded now I think in two or
three different motions about that. But they keep they keep bringing
this up over and over and over again. I don't know why they have
never responded to it. That declaration from that person doesn't
further that but they just keep bringing it up which is very
very very annoying. They're also very eager to say like, "Well,
hold on." Sometimes uh defense is bringing up stuff that's not
relevant exactly to the case, even though even though they keep
bringing up insanely random stupid things. Like here they say
that Bonell is taking advantage of this form to intentionally
cause plaintiff further humiliation by publishing information
saying that isn't this just the point that lawyers do this back
and forth? Like he'll his lawyer say this is irrelevant and their
lawyers will say this is irrelevant. That's what they do. He's
like getting mad at lawyers being lawyers. I don't what the is
he it's all random. It's all random. me mentioning the fact that
plaintiff was the one who suggested making videos and she eagerly
wanted to and all that that that was like improper that I should
have said that. And then in their next claim here, they say that
uh I don't know why Steven is implying that we said 15 witnesses
came forward to say that they'd received videos of Pixie. We
were just saying that 15 people um told Pixie that Bunnel had
randomly shared videos with them that weren't related to her.
Then why the is that being brought up in this complaint? That
has nothing to do with any of this, right? Why? But whatever.
It could have something to do with it and there are legal arguments
for why it could have something to do with it, but I'm gonna
leave it to Pixie to make those. I've kind of I've gone over
all of this kind of I feel like uh opposing council is is acting
in insanely bad faith. Wait, I said that it's no bad faith. We'll
get to the insanely bad faith. One of the annoying things that
they did do you have avenues to complain to the judge? We'll
get to that. Ask me that in 10 minutes. Okay. One of the very
Surely they will. I would just say if there aren't complaints
and if like if the judge doesn't sanction Pixie lawyers, I hope
that would be an indication for you know people watching on Destiny
side that like hey oh Matrix user holy 20 gifted let's go. Holy
moly big 20 gifted for Matrix user. Holy [__] How
much for TTS tonight? It is $2 for TTS tonight. Thank you very
much Matrix user. Holy moly. 20 gifted in in kick chat. Let's
That adds That adds uh another two hours to the stream and it'll
add even more time. Hold on. Uh I think we're basically close
to like the 8 hour stream mark already. Damn. Damn. Damn. We're
getting there. We're getting there. Okay. What was I saying?
Oh, for Destiny's followers, they should just be thinking, okay,
if Pixie's team isn't sanctioned for this, I feel like you have
to start wondering when Destiny is is multiple times saying how
there's like illegal behavior here or like something really bad
happening. This is totally unacceptable. This is totally crazy.
These people are complete rank amateurs. I think you have to
expect that there will be a sanction like an actual sanction,
right? Like he is getting totally, isn't he? Isn't he? But anyway,
we haven't even gotten to the really the ultra bad faith stuff
yet. We're just on the kind of bad faith stuff. We're not on
the ultra bad faith stuff yet. Knowing things about this, aside
from the fact that they keep ignoring aside from the fact that
they keep ignoring over and over again like all of my responses
to everything. Wait. uh have been best to do sorry okay it's
not related to any of this wait at Destiny would it not have
been best to do a joint suit with you against Kiwi farms if you
were actually cons I doubt they will get sanctioned based on
what we know they keep making unforced errors though okay where
are those errors harming them where's the down what like you're
saying unforced errors why does it matter I'm just I'm curious
why people think it matters who told you it matters why do you
think it matters yeah I I would just be curious why you think
concerns with holding any of the like it could have protected
Pixie better if they got the TRO on time. I thought the TR he's
saying the TR is totally baseless. Also, I don't even know if
a TR was appropriate. I think a preliminary injunction is obviously
the most appropriate. I think what they did was they just threw
spaghetti at the wall there because they're like, well, maybe
we can get this faster, but it's realistically they just filed
both at the same time. the more disgusting parties involved with
this accountable for like actual revenge or whatever, then absolutely
a joint suit would have been much stronger. It could have been
a mass tort. It could have been a class action. There would have
been way more resources dedicated to it. The chances of getting
Okay, I don't know why, dude. Destiny is literally the person
who violated their trust, right? They could Destiny can make
the argument that like, okay, I didn't publish it to the internet,
but you you created the situation where it could be published
to the internet, right? If Destiny was hacked, I don't think
a lot of people would be at him, right? If he just got hacked,
nobody would be suing him. It's that the consent violations happened
that he violated those people's trust. That's why he's mad. That's
why he's upset. Or so, sorry. That's why Pixie's mad. That's
why Pixie's upset. Why? Why the would would Pixie see the trust
violation from you and go, "Hey, do you want to sue Kiwi Farms
together?" They're saying, Hold on. They're saying uh a mass
against Kiwi Farms or against the like the person who leaked
it, Latigious Gamer. But like obviously they don't want to go
arm- in-armm with the person who actually violated their trust,
who they trusted, who they've realized is like actually not a
good person. Yeah, of course they don't want to do that. Gross.
The feds interested in it would have been way higher. The pressure
on the other parties. I don't even know if Kiwi Farms would be
a called out party here. I don't feel like way strongly about
that claim, but against the actual person who did all of the
public publishing, absolutely like civily and criminally. No,
I think Syd No, no, no, no, no. That's not what it is here. I
think he talks about it here. He's saying that he wanted a class
action for everybody who had the revenge born posted as in he
was going to join the plaintiffs for that. I believe this was
one of his demands. Yeah, could have been much stronger, but
that's all completely now in the Okay, what was I just saying?
Okay, that's not important right now. What was I just saying?
Oh, but that person probably doesn't have a ton of money. So,
okay. Oh, okay. I remember now. So, one of the complaints that
I brought up before related to
these comments that he's making like he's saying that like that's
not a stupid thing to take into consideration. Make it having
engaging in a civil case that is going to cost you a lot of money
is pretty stupid if the other person is broke and you don't know
who the they are. So, you got to put you've got to it's not even
just how much money she might get. You got to also take into
consideration the amount of money you have to put in. So yeah,
it's just like he makes it sound like oh just a gold digger.
That's not what that is. That's just like you have to make logical
decisions to not bankrupt yourself over absolute nonsense.
Like Taylor Swift, right? Sue someone that Okay. Yeah. But I
I think that uh I mean if you're say Yeah. I mean, your argument
of like not wanting to be involved because like he's a piece
of that they're currently engaged. I just think it's like that
would also be a conflict of interest though, wouldn't it? Can
you realistically be engaging
uh in your own lawsuit lawsuit with somebody whilst at the same
time helping the other one? I don't know how that works. I think
they should be able Yeah, it doesn't doesn't really I just want
to make it clear that I believe he offered to fund the other
lawsuit. Yeah, but who is he even suing? He doesn't even know
Kiwi Farms or um or the the leaker. And yeah, I I agree with
you that there's no reason that they would join that. Like there's
obviously they're they're upset with the person who violated
their trust, right? Like that is the person who betrayed them.
Yeah, but there's also could never have happened. His would never
have been leaked or sorry, their would never have been leaked.
There's also like additional influences there. I don't think
Pixie would want to take on Kiwi Farms hers or be associated
with somebody's suit against Kiwi Farms because that's just going
to be a lot of negativity that could get directed at her, right?
When she's already in like a place as it is. Why would she want
that when she won't get anything back from it? Like it's like
what does she gain from this? I don't know. Yeah, I think that's
totally reasonable as a reason to not want to go in for sure.
and suing would be absolutely worthless if they even figure out
who the she is. Yeah, we'll see to that the big someone says
they he talks about their identity 20 page that they filed. Oh
my god.
Is that so they know that their complaint has a fatal flaw meaning
one of the ele they haven't met any or they're missing one of
the elements to the federal statute. Remember an element is a
necessary part of a thing. Okay, they're missing one of the elements
of that statute. meaning that none of the behavior that they
allege happened were even in date range of the statute. And if
that's the case and that element is gone, that means that that
cause of action is gone, which means that the court lacks subject
matter jurisdiction to hear the case, which means the case gets
dismissed. In a response to our response to their request for
preliminary motion or preliminary injunction, they bring on another
magical declarant. I won't say her name because they tried to
file it redacted but I believe in the already talked about it
multiple times already commented on this person's reputation
and he's been probably chastised by his lawyer and told to shut
the up Steve. Steve could you shut the up um yeah although we
will later find out he leaked more DMs from her yesterday I believe.
So cool redacted filing. They called this person Abby MC. Um
so who knows who that is I guess. Okay, there are a few annoying
problems with this filing. Hold on. I'm trying to see what is
public on here. Oh, yes. Please, God. No. Stop. This is a little
disjointed now, but I'll tie it all together for you at the end
for what I am pretty sure I understand what's happening. Destiny,
is it not worth it just cuz you can't pay? I don't know how it
works if you can't pay penalty or summons. Well, it's not worth
that because just it's so much more of a like it would be a very
it would be a very strong looking case if you had five or six
plaintiffs that were altogether in either a mass tort or a class
action against a singular defendant who was alleged to have done
and you would go on the men's rhea here. You would say like an
actual like revenge like publication who could still do the same
thing over and over again. By the way, that would be a very strong
civil case. That would be an un lossable civil case. Uh, and
it would almost certainly, well, I shouldn't say almost certainly,
but it would have very strong legs to get carried by the FBI.
Wait, why? Hold on. Can somebody explain to me why having anybody
else? Why? Why it's not an unlusible case for Destiny by himself?
What? How is it a lossable case if it's just Destiny by himself?
A bunch of videos of Destiny and like nobody who nobody else
knows. Bunch of videos of Destiny jerking himself off, right?
Like like literally he it should be totally unlable if it's just
him. He also said he was the biggest victim with the most demonstrable
harm. So why would it matter if that's true? Why does he need
the girls then? I don't know as well in a submission to the DOJ
cuz now you've got multiple plaintiffs. You could do, you know,
discovery work during a civil case and everything like it would
just it would have a lot of legs to stand on. Okay. There's literally
no discovery. Those plaintiffs don't even need to have there's
no discovery they could do. All the discovery is through you.
What? I there's no reason. Oh, hold on. Look, it's me and Queen
again.
Um,
oh, I will I hold Hold on. We'll we'll let this go. Yeah, I just
I the the case is the same. The case is literally the same. If
it's just him, it should be unlusable. Okay, hold on. Okay, so
this was the declaration that was submitted. Okay, so Okay, few
things. All right, one, first issue. No, no, wait. I'll get to
this. Hold on. Let me read through this first. Okay. Opposing
council is incredibly obstinate and combative. All right. Generally,
litigants will hate each other, right? It's civil court. You're
suing somebody. Okay, you're upset. Opposing council should be
their lawyers. They don't have a personal stake in it. You know,
they do phone calls. They try to represent their clients best,
but they're not like actually, you know, angry or obsessed with
each other. I don't think that's been the case here. Okay. I
think we filed yesterday a statement in response to as part of
their 11th hour submission to try to save their preliminary injunction
and the entire case. They bring in they bring in this other person.
Again, he keeps like save the entire case. If they hadn't filed
the preliminary injunction, they could have just filed these
affidavit and amended the complaint, right? The issue is they
actually have an active motion that has a deadline on it. So,
they're literally responding. They're just responding. This is
the place where it needs to be responded to right now. You've
actually motioned to have this this motion dismissed because
you are saying that they don't have any evidence of this happening
after the date, right? So, they introduced this evidence as response
in a response to that and said, "Here it is. Here's our evidence
now. It's this affidavit." Right? Like probably if this preliminary
injunction hearing hadn't existed, they would just go and they
would uh Oh, one second. What is that? Is that a primer? I think
there was a primer. Uh Robif Hold on. I lost it. It was white
text on the background. Rob 5205, thank you for the primer. Appreciate
it, buddy. Yeah. So, I just lost where I was in my head. Oh,
yeah. It was just a It was a like a response. That's where you
would file it. They're under time pressure and you were trying
to get the the preliminary injunction dismissed. That's where
they would file it first and then they will amend the complaint
probably right after this whose name is redacted. Okay. When
you redact somebody's name or when you file something under seal,
okay, just to be clear, that filing is protected from the public.
It's so that the public can't see it. You can't hide from the
defendant. Okay? It doesn't work. I don't even know why I have
to say this cuz it's so obvious. You can't have anonymous and
random witnesses or accusers come forward and not reveal that
person and throw them on to cases. I think we literally all agree
with this. I think probably his comments the the pretense the
pretext they have for this is hey Destiny you already tried to
malign this person publicly before like before the seal was uh
put in. We're trying to seal this officially because you keep
maligning these people publicly. We want this to be official
through the judge and we will give you the identities of the
other people after. We don't want it to not be under seal and
you malign these other people because we don't we don't trust
you. Literally anytime we've had conference with your lawyer,
your lawyer has revealed these things to you and you've gone
on stream and talked about it. How do we know you won't do that
in this case as well? You seem to not care about doing it at
all. You seem to keep doing it over and over and over again.
I think that's a totally reasonable thing. And if you need the
identities, then the judge can just give you an extension on
your response if you have to respond to this or something, right?
Like he's he's invented a problem here that doesn't exist at
the 11th hour to to claim that they're willing to test whatever.
And it's literally I think it's just for his chat. I think it's
just so they have a way to stand behind him still. And if you
go through it's funny cuz we we didn't realize this but it's
like Destiny's entire career is just the most effective way of
victimizing himself. He's like figured that out. He is the most
effective self victimizer whatever without the other person even
knowing who it is to be able to defend themselves. Like it's
and I would call it a procedural violation but it's also like
it's more than that. Like it's I don't know if it's sanctionable
behavior but it's like what the is happening right now? So we
filed a response. Okay. In connection with her motion for preliminary
injunction, plaintiff moves. So moving means that you're filing
something with the court. A motion. Movement. Motion. Lol. Plaintiff
moves to file under seal three anonymous declarations. Plaintiff's
motion should be denied for three reasons. One, plaintiff failed
to meet and confer prior to filing her motions. Okay? So again,
I don't know how it's shown in TV shows, but like you don't typically
just file something with the court and the other party's like,
"Oh, we got to read the f. What are they talking about? Oh, you
have meet and confus beforehand." Remember, the court is here
as kind of like a mediator, especially pre-trial, to kind of
like help both sides file stuff and get everything. They're literally
responding to you. They're literally just responding to you.
I don't know why. Yeah, I I would say before introducing a motion,
but I do you have to mean Maybe you do have to meet and confer
every time. um on the record. You should be having meet and confers
in between filings to figure out like what are you guys going
to file? Okay, well this is probably going to be response and
then we'll have this on the record. You're not just supposed
to be randomly throw. They did reach out to meet and convert.
They I mean they reached out to meet and confer like 3 hours
before the deadline or something like like very very shortly
before the deadline. I would say I don't know exactly how this
has gone. I think Pixie's team is probably going to argue that
they're concerned about um like witnesses leaving again, right?
or something along those lines. But it was right after Abby signed.
Well, if that's true, then like yeah, I I don't know what to
say. Like it seems like if that's how that happened, then I I
guess this is how they had to file things. Anyway, um yeah, like
then then you just extend you just extend timelines and the judge
will like get you the information you need. Throwing into the
docket to to see what happens. All right. So, one plaintiff failed
to meet and confer prior to filing her motion. So, that means
that they filed something. They filed a redacted filing without
us even knowing who the person is. And then two, plaintiff refuses
to identify the names of the declarance to defendant Binell's
council. Okay, we'll get to that. And then three, the federal
rule and statute upon which plaintiff relies are not applicable
here. At 7:59 p.m. EDT on Friday, plaintiff's council emailed
the undersign stating pursuant to local rule 7.1 subsection A3,
we are meeting and conferring on the following motions. Motion
to file under seal certain documents and it proposed order. motion
for leave to exceed page limit on reply memorandum um because
they wanted to file an extra long uh insane reply instead of
just normal 10 pages. The documents to be filed under seal are
certain statements by witnesses which purpose is to keep their
names out of the public. You and your client will know their
identities because you have to. Duh. I apologize for not reaching
out before it's been an intense week. What are you doing so much
with your time that why are you taking this case on if you don't
have the time or resources for it? They already used this excuse
to be 6 weeks late in filing for their TTRO, which the judge
excoriated. Uh to be fair, I think the judge could say, "I won't
take this as an excuse again." I do. I think the judge probably
will say, "Uh, but as Cyber pointed out, apparently this is right
after Abby signed." So, if that's the case, I think they have
a reason to say like, "Hey, we've been trying to get all this
stuff done. We literally were at the 11th hour and we filed this
as soon as we can." That seems reasonable, but I I think the
judge probably is not going to like hearing again. I I probably
agree with this. The judge won't like hearing, hey, you're too
busy to have this case. Why don't you hire more people them for
it was stale. It was kicked like for no other reason just because
I don't even know if she analyzed much of the merits of it. It
was just stale. It was 6 weeks old. How you filing a temporary
restraining order 6 weeks after your complaint, but whatever.
Okay. So, at 11:40 p.m. EDT on May 2nd. Okay. 11:40 p.m. EDT.
So, 4 hours. No. Yes. So, 4 hours later. Okay. Plaintiff filed
her motion for leave to file declarations under seal. And then
25 minutes later, uh, EDT on Saturday, May 3rd, after the deadline
to file a reply papers, plaintiff filed the declarations in redacted
form at 10:00 a.m., so filing everything redacted. The only the
only argument Destiny has, he harps on the redactions. I think
this is totally okay. I think this is 100% okay under the the
local rules and everything. probably there will be some argument
of if you're filing this you I believe in the federal rules for
civil procedure there seems to be something that says you have
to give the um local rules do require attorneys to meet and confer
or make reasonable efforts to confer on the most non-disruptive
motions on most non-disrupt dispositive motions. Yeah. Okay.
But they did try to meet and confer um but it it was late but
it was right after they got the information they were putting
in their thing. So I again it's we'll see how it goes for this.
Uh the unredacted filings through Pacer or sorry the redacted
filings through PACE are totally reasonable. On May 3rd, Bonell's
council requested unredacted copies of plaintiff's filings. Despite
repeated requests, plaintiff refused to reveal to Bonell the
names of her declarance. While this opposition is directed to
plaintiff's motion to file seal also opposes plaintiff make a
request when we're allowed a small break. There is just something
I need to share or because it's eating in my brain. It's completely
unrelated. It's just a stupid funny thing. I just need to share
it with somebody. But let me know when we're allowed to have
a break. Just you might as well just go now. It's all good. I
don't speak deprivation. But I saw a Tik Tok earlier that said
like the start of you know that song losing my religion. How
the guy singing it sounds exactly like Trump. And now I can't
get it out of my head. I need other people to listen to this.
I'm not losing my mind. He sounds You send me Send me the Tik
Tok right now, Kelly. Send me the TikTok. Send you the I just
send you the video. It's fine. Yeah, do it. I don't even know
what we're talking about. You not know this song.
Oh, yeah. No, I definitely just like it's like the star. I can't
I'm here. It's Sorry if you needed a palette cleanser. That was
like it.
Well, apparently right now. It's literally a stop just as he
starts singing and it's just the start of it. I cannot hear it
now. Sorry. I gotta ruin for everybody.
It's bigger. It's bigger than you are not mess.
Now I'm not going to be able to hear it. Neither will you. So
if I have to suffer or have to suffer. You've cursed everybody.
You've cursed so stupid. I'm sorry. You've cursed everyone, Kelly.
Thank you. Oh, it's just it's like I get songs stuck in my head
every day. I don't know if that's something that happens to everyone
every day or if it's more of an occasional thing for normal people,
but this is going to be stuck in my head for the next week now.
So, that's great. All right. Okay. I could hear it bigger and
bigger. Yeah, I could hear it for sure. Belated request to Yeah.
Yeah. Pages limitations for its reply brief. Plaintiff failed
to meet and confer prior to filing her motion and unilaterally
certified those purported efforts. Plaintiff did not carefully
edit her reply papers prior to filing their repetitive, wordy,
improperly formatted and contained a myriad of extraneous and
irrelevant information. The court should constrain plaintiff
to the 10-page limit that they didn't need to file. And if we
would have had to meet and confer beforehand, we probably wouldn't
have okayed. I would imagine we would have fought on this motion
to exceed page limit cuz it's they didn't need 20 pages to say
a bunch of like Okay. Um, okay. The local rules require a filer
filing a redacted exhibit to contemporaneously serve a version
of the exhibit upon all council that is either unredacted or
that contains only those redactions authorized in connection
with producing a document to another party in discovery. Today,
plaintiff has not complied. Instead, plaintiff argues that because
she elected to file redacted declarations under local rule 53
subsection B1, she is somehow excused from the requirements of
subsection F of the local rule and contends that Bell has no
right to receive the unredacted documents at this time. So, I
think this could be a poor possibly a poor legal argument. Yep,
I totally agree. This could be a poor legal argument. I don't
think it matters. I think they'll literally just opt to the judge
and say like say what should happen like this has no effect on
the case. It will have no effect on the case when it goes to
trial. There's just no downside to doing it this way other than
Destiny's like ass pained which for a lot of us is kind of an
upside. So I'm plaintiff provides no support or maybe I'm crazy
and the lawyers will be like sanctioned or disbarred for this.
I don't know. I kind of doubt it for this contention. At a minimum
bin should be permitted to know the identities of the purported
witnesses who are providing testimony against him. Further plaintiffs
reliance on rule 26C1 of the federal rules of civil procedure
and 15 USC. Again, they've never said that they will that they
will withhold forever. They've never disagreed that he has the
right to see those things. They've just agreed that he has a
right to see those things before the judge makes a ruling. B6851
is entirely misplaced as those authorities have no bearing on
her motion to file under seal. Rule 26 pertains to seeking a
protective order in connection with discovery. Um, this another
federal procedure. The code section provides that the court may
grant injunctive relief maintaining the confidentiality of a
plaintiff using a pseudonym. Violating the local rules is a federal
crime. Well, they're saying that so I understand that you shouldn't
just like openly violate, but they're making an argument for
why they are like in violation of one section. They're saying
this section supersedes. I assume there will be a a ruling there
and then based on what what is like true and based on the arguments
they make, there will be something. Oh, you're joking. I was
like, okay. I was like, maybe maybe. Holy [__] that
seems crazy. But I did see the one thing that I think is really
important to to highlight in the local rules is that it says
explicitly that violations here or anybody that is sanctioned
with regards to these local rules that it has no effect on the
case at all. So So like it would only be sanctions on the lawyers.
And I just don't understand why like u why lawyers who have like
a successful practice in Florida would be filing stuff that's
like totally like that's going to risk their reputation or risk
them getting sanctioned. Seems kind of odd to me. But yeah, neither
is applicable here. a witness or somebody else is not a plaintiff.
Like and also like yeah no this is stupid. Um for the forgoing
reasons bon request the court deny plaintiff's motion to file
under seal and order plaintiff to file unredacted versions of
the declarations or strike them from the record. Okay so here
are the emails um back and forth. So this is from um their lawyer
on May 2nd. Good evening. We are having a lot of trouble uploading
some of the exhibits. We tried for a couple of hours without
success with some of them. attached is the full set of exhibits
to plaintiffs um Jane do declaration that will be eventually
uploaded. We apologize for inconvenience and we'll try to solve
the issue over the weekend or as soon as we get some guidance
from Pacer. Thank you. And then obviously my Okay, so that seems
like probably the kind of thing that um isn't that the kind of
thing where like the judge would say, "Oh, you had issues with
Pacer. Like I'm not that worried." Says, "Can you please provide
us with he now unfortunately we do have a typo here. I will be
getting reimbursed for this email. They better not have charged
me for sending it. He says unreacted copies. He means unredacted
copies. Okay. So, my lawyer says, "Please provide us with unredacted
copies of your filings immediately." So, to be clear, we should
have these before they're filed with the court. Right. How are
you filing contemporaneously? Doesn't that mean at the same time?
Well, I'll get more. And then this this lady responds, "Upon
the ruling of the court on our motion to file the unredacted
exhibits under seal, we will proceed to file the unredacted versions
with the court, at which point you can access them. I would appreciate
a response to my email dated April 28, 2025 regarding the Discord
subpoena." Okay. Excuse me. What? You don't get to file anonymous
claims that you've unilaterally redacted with the court to make
publicly available to you do get to do that. Actually, you you
do actually get to do that. Um there's basically the only argument
he has again is just that she should be able to send to Brettler
unredacted copies to support other motions that you filed and
then if the court rejects your motion to seal you can just strike
those and I have no idea you never make available to me who any
of the people are. That's insane. You can't like if this was
the way that court worked. I could basically just say oh by the
way I have 10 people and all of them are jumping on board saying
that you're um that you're uh the plaintiff is a murderer by
the way. All 10 of them are jumping on. All of their names are
redacted. Uh but don't worry, I filed with the court to to ask
to to file the Again, I'll just remind you that basically they
said once the motion is granted, we will give you the identities.
So if they are going to be on the record, we will give you the
identities. If they're off the record and then if you deserve
the if you need if basically the judge says you should have had
access to the identities, then we'll also give them to you. You
literally the only way you won't get these is if you weren't
entitled to them or if the judge decides you're not entitled
to them. you are literally pained for no reason under seal which
also I don't even know why that would matter because when you
file under seal I still get those names you still make those
available to me the filing under seal just protects them publicly
right but imagine you doing this and then the court says well
no we're not going to agree to that and you're like okay well
in that case then I take them back especially when this is the
only person by the way that keeps the entire complaint alive
this is the only because the the whoever AbbyMC is in the declaration
we don't know who that person is I mean it's already it's literally
assigned I believe it's a signed affidavit already like that
whether or not it's redacted that is already evidence whether
or not you know they're like I I think this is maybe misinterpreting
I don't think Abby can I don't think you can undo a signed affidavit
you could probably decide you're not going to comply or something
but then I think you would basically be saying if you're not
complying you'd be opening yourself up to perjury charges right
I don't even know how that works I think if you signed an affidavit
you could be subpoenaed to testify I think it's funny how his
lawyer said shut the up and how his behavior is so different,
but he'll still spur in his chat. So, I don't know. Yeah, Laticia
Gamer, if you're here or Wendy or whoever the is that not like
I thought I I don't think this is something you could take back.
It's a signed affidavit. And as we'll learn later, also I believe
Abby served him with like a demand letter and and claims that
she is has been violated under the the same law, right? The ABMC
person. He he leaks that in his chat. But whoever that person
is is the only person that keeps this entire complaint alive,
right? So obviously my uh lawyer responded and he said, "Without
the court ruling on your motion to seal, you filed redacted declarations.
Please send me the unredacted versions." In his belated meet
and confer to me, your co-consel represented, "The documents
to be filed under seal are certain statements by witnesses which
purpose is to keep their names out of the public. You and your
client will know their identities." We do not, right? He knows
who it is. So does he knows who Abby MC is? He's already made
that clear he knows who that is. But now he's acting stupid.
So it seems more reasonable that he wants to get Aby's doc's
information. I don't I don't see any other like probably. Yeah,
he probably already has it. I like he probably he almost certainly
already has it, right? Like Darius would have had it. She literally
was on a lease with them or she was living in their house, right?
Possibly. In which case, why why all of this then? Yeah. Yeah.
Uh I don't know. Um but what was I going to say? Yeah. I sorry.
Why all of this is he needs to make himself a victim. He needs
to make Pixie side look like crazy or something. He's just making
something up like like basically he probably has a real argument
in that contemporaneously with these redacted motions being filed.
You should give us the unredacted copies. That is under the law
like how it should go. I think we'll see. We'll see exactly what
happens here. But I think probably the argument from Pixie side,
I would imagine, is we don't trust you with this information
until you're actually ordered by the court to maintain privacy.
And I think that is a totally justified thing. And I think if
they show the logs from DG chat, him leaking Aby's DMs, him talking
about Abby, calling her crazy and insane and unhinged, I think
the judge will go, well, I understand that like this this didn't
happen as is appropriate, but I do believe that there was a reason
for that. That's what I think. But hey, maybe the judge will
go, no, actually, you're sanctioned and publish all of their
identities. tube said is probably true as well, right? If her
name is put publicly, he can just keep referencing the court
docs and not have to like harass and doc threat her directly
because he can't really do that. He can doc threat you and Queman
and uh threaten to you, but because you're not plaintiffs, I
don't think he can do it to me either. Well, when I say can do,
I mean within the the you know, like um it's not as uh pertinent
to the case, right? Like cuz there's some plaintiffs involved.
If he threatens to dox, harass, and kill them, that's going to
look even worse, right? Yeah. Yeah. Sure. But here's the unfortunate
thing for Destiny that I don't know if he's even considered this
yet, but I am the person who informed him of these leaks when
they initially happened and I am the person who talked to him
about these leaks in private multiple times. So, I believe that
very likely makes me a viable witness to this case. Yeah. So,
him trying to talk about getting me killed and seems a little
bit absurd to me. Um, people have tried to argue that I'm not
connected to the case at all, but that's completely I mean, it's
not a good idea, but until you were officially like doing something
similar to Abby or something, um, he can probably get away with
it. But what I'm saying is it would be worse if he harassed the
plaintiffs or the character witnesses. I'm not sure what Abby
is. What What is her What is What is she? Uh, I don't know what
the term is for somebody who signed an affidavit. I don't know.
Okay. Well, a witness maybe. I'm not sure. Well, whatever. Their
their current position is a bit more important. I'm pretty sure
they still shouldn't be harassing you either. I'm just saying.
I think I'm pretty sure it's like actually like technically actually
quite bad for his court case to be harassing me. Yeah. No, I
don't. It's not a benefit. I think it's actually probably way
worse than he's willing to admit or most people around him are
willing to admit. But obviously if it looks if it's to the point
where he's harassing the women involved and saying people should
go kill them, that's like another level of escalation where he
looks very unhinged. Whereas he could just force them to give
over Aby's actual identity and then just casually keep showing
it on his stream without looking deranged even though we know
what he's doing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Please provide that information.
Thank you. His response was, "To be clear, because of your client's
statements related to Jane Doe and any potential witnesses, we
had to file these under seal. Once the court rules on the motion,
we will proceed accordingly. If the court grants the motion,
you will know their identities. Thank you. This is not allowed.
You're not allowed to do this." Number one. Number two, this
is more irrelevant statements. They try to bring up I do I do
kind of agree with this. They're not irrelevant statements, though.
They're not irrelevant statements, which is why it's being brought
up in a conference. By the way, I I will say he's going to get
mad about irrelevant things being introduced and it's going to
be very funny to me like oh my god he made these statements about
who was it like just and these people I'll just point out that
I I believe is this uh he he has threatened to to people sure
or he's talked about getting people killed but now the person
introducing it here from the conference is Breler right is that
not the case have nothing to do with this case they're not uh
no I absolutely no so I would say the first thing I could like
testify to if I had to is the date that I explained to Destiny
that these leaks happened. And I could testify to the fact that
despite me telling him, hey, you need to delete that message.
One of his first reactions was uh just I I hope they don't start
leaking stuff cuz there's hella videos of me sucking on that
in that message chain. And I told him to delete that cuz I didn't
want to accidentally leak that on stream because at that point
I actually was concerned about this person. Also, none of the
videos had been leaked yet. This was just the lore in southern
DMs, right? But I'm the person who knows when I went and actually
talked to him and said, "Hey, just just so you know, like this
is happening and he expressed that he had private videos in there."
So then I would love to know, hey, in terms of damage mitigation,
when did he go and get rid of videos? When did he go and delete
videos? Did he do it before they had downloaded all the videos?
Did he do Sorry, did he do it before all the videos were leaked
or after or when? So I I think I actually have quite relevant
testimony to give to this case. That's always been the case.
Him constantly trying to attack and break me seems pretty insane.
But you know what? I I Okay, I listen. I can't really say. I'm
not a lawyer. It seems like that would be relevant to this case.
No. When determining damages, am I crazy how how expeditiously
he acted in in terms of getting the uh like stuff removed? Is
that not like a material fact of this case? I would assume so.
In terms of calculating, they're not part of this complaint.
They're not declarants. They haven't signed affidavit. I don't
even know if they're called out in any part of this. You can't
just bring on random statements and say like, "Well, now because
of that, we're going to break federal rules of civil procedure
and just do wild unhinged." It's like, what? You can't just You're
the one doing wild unhinged. Why are you telling people that
you want to get them killed? You're going to sit there being
like, "Oh, these lawyers are being unreasonable that they're
bringing up my unhinged." Bringing up your unhinged is not being
unhinged. Yeah. I I feel like the unhinged conduct here is talking
about trying to get people killed. I probably just file stuff
with the court without making any of it known to me. And then
if the court says we're not going to file this and just and just
just unfile it. You can't do that. Um and so so um this might
be a little sarcastic or snarky. And if the court doesn't grant
your motion, their identities remain anonymous. Um, and then
they don't respond and then council and then so and then my lawyer
says again, "Despite our repeated requests, you have failed and
or refused to provide us with unredacted copies of the declarations
you improperly filed with your reply papers on Friday. Your continued
failure and a refusal to provide the requested Darius is just
Destiny Jr. I think Darius is more like Destiny with like a I
don't know like a 30 to 40 IQ penalty. So like going from 120
down to like
Yeah. documents violates local rule 5.4. Although I will say
despite the the intellect debuff, Darius does actually have testosterone.
I saw a clip of him yesterday or something working out. That
guy looks fantastic. That guy is that guy's starting to bulk
up. Okay, thank God. Des Darius goes and he's consistent in the
gym and he gets results. Destiny goes and is consistent in the
gym and literally nothing happens. Four, if you do not immediately
provide us with the unredacted filings, we will so advise the
court and seek appropriate remedies, including but not limited
to striking the pleadings, relying on the unauthorized declarations,
and the imposition of judicial sanctions against you and your
client. All rights reserved. Sincerely, and then their reply,
Mr. Breler, note that local rule 5.4b 4 B1 provides in relevant
part quote if prior to the issuance of a ruling on the motion
to fall under seal. The moving party elects or is required to
publicly file a pleading motion memorandum or other document
that attaches or reveals the content of the proposed sealed material.
Then the moving party must redact from the public filing all
content that is the subject of the motion to file under seal.
So I don't know if redacting all content means just what you
want redacted or means everything that that person is alleging.
I don't actually know the rule. It's it's literally what is like
basically when they said we're sealing this. I'm assuming the
proposal to seal says, "Hey, we want um we want like the identities
protected and probably gives maybe gives like a reason." I actually
don't know. Hold on. Let me take a look. I that would be my assumption,
but I have no idea actually. I don't know if I actually read
the the direct motion to seal. These are replies in supportive
motion. Where is the losing my religion? I'm looking for seal.
I'm losing my mind. says me on sleep that probation. Hold on
a second. Notice submitting amended certificate of conferral.
Both motions certifying the council for movement made an effort
today to confer with opposing council. Okay, hold on. What is
this? This was filed before Okay. Uh on May 2nd, pursuant to
local rules. So meet and confer. So they did the meet and confer
before filing these two things. plaintiff included a certificate
of conferral with both motions certifying that the council for
movement made an effort today to confer with opposing legal counsel
regarding the relief sought in the motion was unable to confer
in light of the time-sensitive nature of this matter. The motion
is being filed in an abundance of caution. Council will Oh, see
like this is what they're saying. We're basically filing this
because we don't want to get for like time penalties or whatever.
Like we don't want to get by not publishing uh by the deadline.
So, we're we're out of an abundance of caution. We're gonna we're
going to publish this and we will wait to speak to the judge
or something. Right. Seems reasonable, seems normal.
Um, council will continue to make diligent efforts to confer
with opposing council and come to an agreement upon same council
will update the court. Although plaintiff's attempt to confer
with the opposing council was not made until almost 8 p.m. on
Friday, May 2nd due to time constraints. The request would have
been received by defendants lead council Mr. Andrew Breler at
5:00 p.m. his time. Docket 44 was not filed until 10:49 p.m.
EST, and DE48 was not filed until 11:41 p.m. EST. Mr. Brent was
aware of our filing deadline, but did not respond. Due to this,
we notified the court that we would provide an update to our
meet and confer efforts. As of now, council for defendants have
not provided any response to our request. So, they basically
say, "We tried to confer. We couldn't confer." On May 3rd, defendants
council, Mr. Brent, responded to the meet and confer request
regarding our request for leave to file the three declarations
under seal by demanding the undersigned council immediately provide
him with unredacted versions of the three three declarations.
As of now, various communications have been exchanged, but no
consensus has been reached. The undersigned council has communicated
to Mr. Brentler that the that pursuant to local rule 5.4 4 B1.
He will receive unredacted versions of the declarations after
the court approves of the motion at docket 48 and they're filed
under seal. These declarations contain highly sensitive private
and confidential information regarding the non-consential distribution
of explicit materials and related communications involving the
witnesses plaintiff and other individuals. Oh, the witnesses
plaintiff and other individuals. These witnesses only agreed
to provide their testimony if their identities can be kept private
under the protection of the court. For all of the reasons more
fully uh for all of the reasons more fully set forth in plaintiff's
motion, it is critical to the protect the identities of these
declarants. The undersigned council has also explained to Mr.
Breler, the defendant has full unredacted substantive content
of the declarations. The only redacted portions are those that
would reveal the identities of the declarance. There can be no
legitimate urgency for defendant to know these witnesses legal
identities. That information does not alter the substantive facts
or council's ability to defend his client in these proceedings.
As of now, despite repeated efforts, the parties have been able
to unres unable to resolve this issue accordingly. Plaintiff's
updated certificate of conferral set forth below as follows.
So again, so no identities. So the identities No, no, no, no,
no. This is the identities will be provided to both the court
and to Destiny. Um through like Pacer, you can file things under
seal, but they didn't file them directly. They did the public
thing. Hold on a second. Let me check this out real quick. Uh
uh uh uh
uh. Hold on. I'm looking for Somebody just said check research.
We won't Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. So, there's another piece.
See, federal rules of civil procedure, page 26, C1G. ABMC witness
B discuss their own victimization at the hands of the defendant
as well as private encounters. Their declarations include details
that may otherwise reveal their identities and subject them to
continued harm and harassment by the defendant and/or his followers.
Witness A also discusses details of her own private encounters,
potential non-consensual distribution of content by the defendant,
and her private communications with the plaintiff. If her identity
is not protected, witness A would face the same type of harassment,
the other victims of the defendant's behavior have suffered.
So basically, they're saying Destiny has gone to harass people
and we believe that if these identities are revealed, his audience
will go to harass people. I'm sorry, but that just tends to be
like that is a real thing. Yes. Uh, I don't know what Federal
Rules of Civil Procedure 26 C1G is, but should check it out.
Uh, what's up, Box? How's it going? All right. Are we back to
this? Oh, sorry. Somebody did link it here. One second. Oh, no.
This is a different one. Oh, whatever. It's fine. Okay. Sorry.
I'm I'm looking at something in my I tried to read the underline,
but I couldn't interpret what that meant. However, again, this
doesn't mean that you're allowed to not make it available to
me. This just means that you might be able to preemptively file
something and redact it publicly with the court, but this doesn't
mean you can keep it from opposing counsel from the defense.
You it's like a fundamental rule in in US legal system. So let's
say that you had like a mafia case, okay? Like a mafia case,
you're doing RICO in a mafia case and you had people who filed
as witnesses under seal. I guess this is a civil case. Let's
say let's say it's a civil case against like a person who is
known to be dangerous, like a mafia boss. Is there no way you
could protect their identity from the plaintiff and from their
council? That seems like it wouldn't be possible. Like, not that
you're protecting it from the court. The court would know it,
but is there absolutely no way to do this? Um, I understand that
there is a there is a constitutional right to face your accuser,
right? That I think that's a constitutional right, but like I
I would assume that there's some like obviously I don't think
Dusty's, you know, having people killed. I I don't. But I do
think there's some some rule about this. But rule 26 in control
F section. Okay, hold on. So they cite I forget which one they
cited. Uh I'm not going through this right now. We can go through
this after for federal rules of civil procedure as well. Um I
don't mind going through it after. I want to get you know allowed
to be confronted with your accusers because remember we're in
the discovery phase now. Who am I even supposed to request discovery
on if I don't even know the names of the people that are supposed,
you know, witnesses or people that are supporting plaintiff's
claims? Um but plaintiff elected to again um for two of them
it literally says when they flew to specific locations, right?
That's the funny thing. Also, Destiny literally leaked DMs with
Abby yesterday. So, he obviously knows who Abby is. I I actually
don't even know like the only thing the only thing that makes
sense to me is he just wants these things to be like put out
publicly. Like this is total fake outrage because for one of
them he would probably have like literal receipts like actual
receipts. You should know exactly who these people are but um
I don't know. Yeah. Who attached the declarations to the reply
and filed a simultaneous motion to file under seal. Defendant
has no right to receive the unredacted documents at this time.
Excuse me. What? It would also be highly negligent if we were
to provide to your client the unredacted documents without the
protection of their identities by the court in light of your
client's public statements over the weekend maligning these declarants.
So no, that's not how any of this works. You don't get to just
have random people jump onto a case, mask their identities, not
provide us with copies. So, I believe what they're saying here
is, "Hey, hey, we don't we we feel like it would be crazy to
like provide these identities before there's an official order."
Um, that's why we're doing this. It's not random. It's literally
just saying this is our reasoning. This guy has already like
blinded one of the people who are here. Uh, we believe there
other people are at risk. So, that's our reasoning. Um, I I understand
this might even be in violation of some rule of civil procedure.
I assume there's something under the law that basically says,
"Hey, for some reason this rule of civil procedure is actually
going to like violate somebody else's rights or or harm somebody
else more significantly than uh than taking like a temporary
break here to to consult the judge. I I just don't see again
the the the intense time pressure that's being like feigned here
that a judge can't look at this and make a decision is what seems
totally disingenuous to me of who any of these people are especially
when these other people are making public statements which they
have because one of these people allegedly supposedly possibly
jumped on another stream to talk a little bit about so what the
client has also threatened other individuals that have spoken
out against him in support of the plaintiff none of this has
anything to do with any of this case for Jessica I could I shove
their house to do it I do not want someone or I do want someone
to kill this school though or lab or Mr. or
equ if you really think you have a strong argument here which
fine say you do say okay well I think that the I think defense
is is trying to murder all of the witness or whatever father
I believe they're literally they literally say that the people
have received harassment that is literally in one of the things
hold on they literally do make that argument that's in their
filings what that's in their filings that like basically these
names being known leads these people getting harassed he's being
sneaky he's saying if you think he's being hyperbolic in danger
of being killed build like he's saying, "Oh, if you're worried
about me, then make that well obviously nobody's scared of Destiny.
I can't think of anything less frightening." But what the point
is is like the harassment is bad. It's like the annoying harassment
and like people digging up your and bothering you and causing
you problems, right? And who knows, there might be like some
creepy Destiny stalker fan that would actually be demented enough
to kill someone on his behalf. We don't know. Well, that's that's
the real concern. Yeah. That with the court. File it with the
court. have a judge rule on it, file a motion for it, and then
have a hearing on it. You can't. There's a time pressure, and
out of an abundance of caution, believing that the judge will
see their side of it. They've filed things this way. Just unilaterally
decide, I'm going to uh I'm going to just start having anonymous
witnesses come forward and then file it. See if the court accepts
it. If they don't, then I'll just like strike it from the record.
Moreover, you have the full unredactive unredacted substantive
content of the declarations. The only redacted portions are those
that would reveal the identities of these declarants. There could
be no legitimate urgency for you or your client to know these
witnesses legal identities. That does not alter the facts or
your ability to defend your client in these proceedings. So,
first of all, you don't get to make that decision. Number one.
Number two, you don't get to make that decision unilaterally.
Okay? Number three, you don't again, the motion is not in fact
unilateral. This is what what what is this saying? There's literally
a judge. There's they're literally filing the motion. So, the
judge can rule on the motion. Who in the world is making a unilateral
decision here? No. Like if maybe me having access to that person's
name helps me at some point in discovery when I'm allowed to
make requests like who am I even making a document request to?
Who am I even making interrogatory requests to or demand to formations
to if I don't even know the actual names of the people involved
here? Who's to say that I'm in contact or have contact with any
of them? You you can't do this. Okay, this is you will you will
get that. You you haven't been denied that. that will come. Literally,
literally the lawyer is saying, "Hey, these things will happen.
They are happening." Ridiculous. All right. For these and other
additional reasons, we will not be providing the unredacted documents
unless they are under seal. What is You don't get to make that
decision. Or if you want to wait, then you can wait, but you
can't. The judge gets to make that decision. Listen, if it's
as bad as he says, okay, if it's as bad as he says, then these
people will get sanctioned, right? and they might get sanctioned.
But I think like the concern here is legitimate. The concern
here seems to be backed up with, hey, your client's insane, and
he's going to he like directs harassment at anybody he can, whenever
he can, as often as he can. We think it's inappropriate to not
have these things filed under seal. I understand why they would
like to hide the names, but unfortunately, the procedure in a
civil case don't allow for anonymity from the defendant. They
did not account for online harassment when making the rules.
Uh, yeah. So, that would be the case where they're saying, "This
is why we're handling it this way, and they're letting it go
to the judge." the judge can just say, "Hey, actually, no, you
can't you can't protect that. You have to give them the unredacted
copies." That seems like the most that actually seems like the
most likely thing here that that like the judge will literally
go, "Okay, I will grant your motion to seal, but you must provide
the unredacted copies." Which they already said they would do.
Does anybody want to bet against me on that outcome being the
case? Like, I don't I don't know for sure. Maybe the judge says
I can't see the judge as a way of penalizing the lawyers failing
to follow procedure.
um saying now these have to be like publicly filed unredacted
or something. I just don't see that party fails to provide information
or identify a witness as required by rule 26A or E. The party
is not allowed to use that information or witness to supply evidence
on a motion at a hearing or at a trial unless the failure was
sub substantially justified or is harmless. Oh, substantially
justified. Oh yeah, they're they literally substantially justified
it. Or if they didn't, then the judge will say, "Hey, this isn't
substantial." But it seems like they're literally trying to they're
explaining in the meet and confer exactly why they're doing this.
Oh, good. I didn't know there was an exception vigilant stream,
but thank you for finding it. I appreciate you, buddy. File them
first without us having copies of them. We consider our meet
and confer efforts to have been exhausted. What? At Destiny,
I think he said he'd only submit things if it was the case that
he could remain anonymous. I heard Jess say that on the stream
last. Oh, that's that's me. Yeah, last night. So, here's a stronger
save and I will make I thought about saving these, but I don't
even know. I'm honestly So, I did say, yeah, I basically sec
I'm not as brave as the people who filed here. Okay, I need to
see that this works before I'm interested. I don't want my out
there. I'm sorry. I'm a coward. Okay, I don't want my out there.
So, overall this I think there's a lot of very bad behavior going
on behind the scenes related to this. I already have all of uh
Jessica's contact. The worst behind the scenes behavior has come
from you. If you hadn't leaked your tapes to like a bunch of
random freaks, this wouldn't have happened. Especially your channel.
It is. And also, I don't know what he's he says he has all of
my contact information. I don't know why he says he has all of
my contact information. That seems insane. Sorry. Uh I'm going
to go back, Kelly, just to I heard Jessica say that on the stream
last night. So, here's a stronger save and I will make I thought
about saving these, but I don't even know. I'm honestly so over.
So, so hold on. The thing that he heard me say was I would file
as soon as I know they can protect my identity. Actually, all
this I think there's a lot of very bad behavior going on behind
the scenes related to this. I already have all of uh Jess's contact
info. And why is that relevant? He does this to like try to signal
threats, by the way, and or amp his audience up. This is just
signaling threats like completely. It's It's But I Whatever.
If he If he's going to do something, he's going to do something.
Big scary evil man. Oh, he's so scared. So scared. Oh no. The
fat guy's holding a gun to my head and Kelly is like taunting
him right now. He's literally holding a gun to my head and Kelly's
like taunting him repeatedly. It's It's pretty funny. It's pretty
crazy. and I've already served two opposing council uh discovery
requests related to him and I know a lot about conversations
that have happened and if I don't get copies of all of those
uh that will be relevant to all of these proceedings going forward.
Um and that's true for several people involved then why does
if if you know things like this just say what happened. Wait,
just go say what happened. Why are you why are you burying the
lead here? Just just say the thing. Wait, burying the lead? Did
I just use that right? I don't know if I use that. said I would
I said I would tell Destiny my address if he would pull up, but
we all know he will not pull up. So, Sure. Sure. Don't be scared.
Don't be scared of Destiny. Just a boy. What is What is my contact
information or anything? If if he has an allegation, just make
the allegation that that either think they're clever or cute
or don't know that I'm aware that other people are involved in
this. But here is so here is my really annoying thing related
to this. Okay, this person whoever screen name ABMC is that's
making this um claim about getting a uh getting the video that's
the the relevant subject matter of the complaint from me. I think
that this is all a lie. I think that all of this is perjury and
my conspiratorial thinking is the reason why these were filed
redacted was to keep the name of the person out of direct hands
of us so that the the person's name is AbbyMC. You literally
leaked messages with ABMC yesterday. You literally know exactly
who Abby is. You have ABMC. I don't like that. What do you mean
that the purpose of this is to keep the identity out of your
hands? You [__] slobbering. What in the are you trying
to say right now? Does anybody understand where this is going?
Like dude, this is what I'm telling you. This isn't the same
human being that other people like liked as a as like an online
influencer before. This is embarrassing to watch. Like that I
that I actually like liked watching this person's content embarrasses
me deeply when I see like this perjury. And my conspiratorial
thinking is the reason why these were filed redacted was to keep
the name of the person out of direct hands of us so that the
person could perjure themselves without accountability. That's
what that's not possible. Uh by the way uh from days before the
the actual affidavit were filed, Destiny was already looking
into Abby because apparently as he reveals later, Abby had already
sent him a demand letter. Uh apparently he had violated Abby
in the same way that he violated Pixie. Apparently, again, I
don't know the underlying facts of any of that stuff, so I I'll
just say like apparently this is what he says. This is what it
says in Aby's affidavit. My feeling is um we're going through
the discovery process right now and I'm complying legally with
all my obligations that I'm supposed to meet for everything else.
But I think that I feel like this person was brought in to perjure
themselves on a declaration in order to keep the case alive with
the hopes that they can somehow scrunch up or find something
else in discovery.
So my concern here would be like pretty significantly if you
know that your community knows who this person is and you continue
repeatedly to say that this person is lying and making things
up to harm you then I feel like you are probably directing quite
a bit of harassment their way. It is probably inadvisable from
a legal perspective but hard to say. I love that it it can Jtock
conflates legal and pseudonyms online. Very violet. You're welcome
to join the discord at any time. We love having adiq djers in
here to poke fun at. Um, you're welcome back whenever you like.
I don't know what that means. I think if you think Destiny doesn't
know Aby's legal name when she lived with Darius, I think you
are almost certainly brain damaged. If you think that he doesn't
know her legal name, do you think Abby Hold on. Does Abby say
that that he bought her a flight? Hold on. Let me see this. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Where's Aby's Darius? just
like yeah he's access is talking like he already said he was
asking him stuff right so he's probably been asking everyone
but he probably already knew it doesn't matter hold on very violet
he literally just said that the reason the identity was hidden
was so they could pure themselves without consequence but he
knows Aby's identity and this is the actual main piece of evidence
right now that puts him within Cardi right he literally knows
who this person is so he is just lying clearly right he's just
lying That can't possibly be a reasoning. It can't. It literally
can't possibly be a reasoning. I Okay. Yeah. Anyway, we can continue.
I'm going to find it is incredibly frustrating that I'm having
to waste more time, more money, potentially draw this out depending
on how long they're willing to lie all the way to trial because
this person is making declarations, but why are there no exhibits
attached? If you're literally claiming here that you have uh
screenshots with conversations with other people or you have
screenshots about conversations, why why is that not attached
anywhere? You can file it under seal if you want, but that's
incredibly Yeah. So, here's the thing. Uh, on September 3rd,
2023, Destiny flew me to Miami to meet in person. Did he pay
for this flight without knowing who she was? He obviously knows
her identity, but it needs to be on the docket for it to matter.
Why would it need to be Why could he not just claim that this
is the person and show his like evidence here and say, "We actually
want to go uh and and subpoena this person. We believe they they
perjured themselves." Do you think that like the record of this
happening would just disappear? Why would that happen? Even if
it's strict stricken, the fact that it happened would be something
you could pursue. He's just he's just lying or he's But I I I
mean it seems more likely he's lying. Being weird. Um yeah. So
that's this is really really really really really really annoying.
Um yeah, in docket 65 paragraph 3, they argue they try to confer
before filing, but it's a joke. You should show that. Um, wait
where in docket 56 or docket 65 paragraph 3. Stop. What's the
logic? You get someone for perjury if they lie under seal. Yes.
Behind them doing this. Uh, very violent. There is an exception
to violating the rules for civil procedure if you can sub substantially
give your reasoning. So, it seems like the the lawyers are very
clearly saying, "We understand what you're saying. We believe
that these people will be put at risk by revealing these identities
to you before they're actually protected under seal and you know
you shouldn't be saying them for a fact. That's their argument.
There is there is an exception to uh this ruling for civil procedure
like giving over these identities there the unredacted copies
there is a there is an carve out where if you substantially uh
back up why you've done it it's possible that you you wouldn't
be uh facing like any sanctions for it. I believe they've given
substantial reasoning for it. Now we'll just let it the judge
decide. But there's also no time pressure here. There's no concern.
There's no problems. None of this is under any sort of time uh
time pressure whatsoever. The judge will literally just say what
should have happened and will rule accordingly. Right? If Destiny
should have gotten unredacted copies in the first place and and
the judge doesn't allow them to be filed under seal and they
get redacted, Destiny will still be given those unredacted copies,
Destiny will still be able to pursue whatever he wants against
those people. It's not just like takes back sees nothing happened
here. I think the fantasy is that they're going to find something
else. Or in in my nightmare scenario, I guess, but I guess it's
not really it's not a real Destiny is panicking. Well, I assume
that's why he started to go to fantasy to explain why he's like
why this hasn't been dismissed, right? And conspiracy when when
reality is very difficult for people. They tend to escape into
fantasy, which is what Destiny's doing now. Complaint for me.
By the way, he could still win the case. Like, he could still
be found non-liable on the merits of the case. I have no idea.
Right. We haven't seen the evidence from Abby. We haven't seen
what she has for conversations. We don't know what that is. But
I'm saying that probably he's hearing that this case is going
to keep going from his lawyers or something. Cuz otherwise, I
can't explain the insane fantasizing he's doing. To me, it just
seems like he's starting to act. He's starting to contemplate
conspiracy to explain why why he wanted to happen didn't happen.
Because I guess I'm not a victim or men can't be victims. So,
uh I don't think Wait, hold on. I have to go back and hear that
joke. You should show that. Um, wait, where? In docket 56 or
docket 65, paragraph 3. Stop. What's the logic behind them doing
this? The I think the fantasy is that they're going to find something
else or in in my nightmare scenario, I guess. Um, but I guess
it's not really it's not a real complaint for me because I guess
I'm not a victim or men can't be victims. Oh my
Is it like performance art when you say that you or or men in
general can't be victims? while just immaculately victimizing
yourself to everybody. Is that performance art? I feel like it
should be. It's layered. It's It's a layered performance. It's
very very compelling. So, um I don't think Sorry for me when
I shuck my own hands and clapped. Men can't be victims. So, um
I don't think these are technically private. One of the things
that their council brings up in the email to Andrew is that we
haven't replied to their request to comply with Discord subpoena.
So, opposing council is trying to subpoena me, okay, on Discord
and Instagram for every single video and picture that has been
sent to or received from or has been sent by or received from
my account for 5 years. I would rather myself than give these
disgusting that Oh, that's another reason he needs the lawyers
to be bad, right? Because the if the lawyers are so he's trying
to convince everybody why they should be against the lawyers.
This is why. Well, I could give over all my to Discovery, right?
But that would be disgusting. These people hate me. It's personal
for them. I can't give everything over to Discovery. That would
be insane. That would be insane. Also, it makes me wonder what
kind of other crazy Destiny's been up to if he's scared of that.
Uh, it's just it's going to be very I What have you been doing,
Destiny?
I also think it's unlikely that they would have those things
retained. Um, that would be that would be insane. No judge would
ever make him turn that over. Uh I think that could be another
reason that that a lot of the instances of sharing are being
shared vigilant stream is because if you have a long enough track
record, if you can establish, you know, non-conensual sharing
of imagery across, you know, 2, three years, it's possible. But
none of that that none of the unrelated videos would ever be
just open to anybody, right? That would have to be like sealed
in a private area and like the lawyers would have to go through
probably his lawyers would go through and and take things out
that are unrelated, right? Like they would never ever go through
all of his [__] It would be going through like uh
trying to find the videos of Pixie and you could probably do
that through software pretty easily. That's an insane that is
an insane request. I very violet I just I I'm not going to read
your messages. I just I see Destiny says we will see. Destiny
says we will see. Destiny says I would just suggest that you
try walking away from the computer for like 90 days. Just get
away from streams. See if you regain your own internal monologue
and your own voice. Stop viewing the word world through how Destiny
tells you it is. I that would be the best thing for you. I don't
think you'll do that. I don't think you can do that. But that's
okay. I'm just suggesting it in the context of everything that
this people are capable of. Original thought is about Jesus Christ.
Um but that that was the Discord subpoena that they reply to.
We're absing with that. What an what an unbelievably broad and
disgusting request to make. Yeah, but shouldn't you like talk
about it? But that seems overly broad to me. But you go back
to 2022 Pixie stuff. I would say you'd probably go back to when
the video was recorded and then go from there and then say that
like well you have to have certain things filtered out in some
way. Like I think it's funny that he said that that's a disgusting
request but I don't think he's ever used language that strong
to talk about the disgusting things he did. True. It's apparently
it's really disgusting having your privacy violated like this.
Who would have thought, Kelly? Who would have thought? Apparently
violating my privacy and my my videos. That's really up. Jesus
Christ. Um, yeah. Everything about this case is just like so
gross. Okay. Sorry. You said your paper ri donated $3. You know
what else is broad and disgusting? I do know what you're saying
there. I don't know about the broad part, but yes. Yes, it is
disgusting.
Hold on. I am doing something in the background real quick before
I 65 paragraph 3. Although plaintiff's attempts to confer with
opposing council was not made until almost 8:00 p.m. on Friday,
May 2nd due to time constraints, the request would have been
received by defendants lead council, Mr. Andrew Breler, at 5:00
p.m. his time, California. Wait, what? Although plaintiff's attempts
to confer with the posing council was me when I laugh at the
revenge. Uh, actually, I'm laughing at basically him not wanting
to give things over in discovery to lawyers who are only doing
that through a an investigative pro process, right? I'm not laughing
about the revenge, but again, you're like really really just
incapable of engaging at all was not made until 8:00 p.m. on
Friday. The request would have been received by defendants lead
council at 5:00 p.m. his time, California. Okay. D4 was not filed
until 10:49 EST. So, they made a request to meet and confer at
5:00 p.m. Okay. California time. And then less than 3 hours later,
they filed. So, I think the argument here is the deadline for
them to respond is coming up. Andrew's aware of that. Was he
not checking his email at the end of the day on Friday to see
like, "Hey, are we actually Hey, are we actually doing this?
Hey, are we actually doing this?" You know how Destiny is laughing
and smirking?
Jesus Christ. Keep reading. Um, sorry. Mr. Brenley was made aware
of our filing deadline, but did not respond. Due to this, we
notified the court that we provide an update to our meeting of
her efforts. As of now, council for def I haven't actually read
the spoiling. Sorry. As of now, council defendants have not provided
any response to our request for a meet and confer regarding the
excess pages regarding 48. Plaintiff's motion requests leaves
um for the declarations of three witnesses to be filed under
seal in order to protect their identities. These three declarations
were made in support of plaintiffs reply. The opposition someone
else filed elected to attach redacted versions of these three
declarations to reply brief. The portions of the declarations
that are redacted are only those that would serve to identify
the witnesses. The substantive content is not redacted. What
does this mean? You can't you can't have anonymous accusers coming
forward. What? You can't do that. What is this? Like, you know
everything about the accusers. They just are anonymous. That's
not how this works in court. On Saturday, May 3rd, 2020, I'm
pretty sure they gave their reasoning for why they're doing this
and they're just telling the judge to work it out. The judge
will work it out. There is no time pressure. Destiny's not being
[__] over. There's no problem for him. If if their
reasoning for why they didn't want to hand over those identities
is completely specious, then I believe they will be sanctioned.
If their reasoning is like understandable but not valid, then
I believe that they'll just hand the identities over to Destiny
and say, "Well, you guys you guys had an okay reason, but whatever."
And if the reasoning is like valid, then they won't have the
Well, actually, I think they said they would hand I think Pixie
team said they hand the identities over no matter what, but that
they'd never be posted publicly. So, yeah. Anonymous accuser.
Isn't he being sued by a Jane Doe? Isn't he 25? Defendants council.
Um, what would this be the next day? Yeah. Mr. Breler responded
to the meet and confer request regarding our request to leave
or for leave. Uh, the file responded to the meet and confer request
regarding our request for leave the file the three declarations
under seal to I think there's a timeline by demanding that the
undersign council immediately provide him with unredacted versions
of the three declarations. As of now, various communications
have been exchanged but no consensus has been
The undersigned council has communicated to Mr. Breler that pursuant
to local rule 54 B1, he will receive the unredacted versions
of the declarations after the court approves of the motion at
docket 48 and they are filed under seal. These declarations contain
highly sensitive, private and confidential information regarding
the non-conential speech or materials and related communications
involving the witnesses, excuse me, none of that is the subject
of this case. None of this is relevant to this case, plaintiffs
and other individuals. These witnesses only agree to bri their
testimony if their identities can be kept private under the direction
of the court. again. The uh he keeps saying it's not relevant,
bro. It says plaintiff right there. It says plaintiff. It says
plaintiff. It says plaintiff. It says plaintiff. It says plaintiff
right there. Bro, what are you saying? How is it irrelevant?
Okay, this uh there were some irrelevant pieces, but I'm saying
the plaintiff part. He does the same thing to me when I include
the plaintiff part and he says like, "Yes, that is irrelevant."
It's like, no, the fact that you shared Pixie's video to somebody
else is actually like entirely and absolutely relevant to this
case. This makes more I didn't read this before. This makes more
sense now. Oh my god, I just had a brain blast. Some people have
been communicating with me privately that um should I actually
I don't give a [__] now. They shouldn't be talking
to me privately and you should be communicating only through
your lawyer. And the fact that they've been communicating with
me privately seems to imply to me that there is a heavy amount
of pressure with opposing council to elicit what I would say
are obviously false statements in order to keep this case alive.
And I think that
that's a very direct accusation, is it not? That feels like a
very direct accusation right there. I sure hope that's being
said. I sure hope he's not referring to those Darius DMs cuz
that is not what those say at all. He must be, but he must be.
I I saw in those Darius DMs that Abby said she was trying to
reach out to Destiny. Maybe he talked to her. I have no idea.
Is I think I think I look forward to showing up next court filing.
It feels to me like opposing council is in over their heads.
Don't work in this area of law at all. This Joan Peters person
is a something kind of some kind of immigration lawyer from Puerto
Rico. And this other guy, I guess, is just uh I don't even know
what law he does for everything. Maybe car accidents. I don't
know. Um but they're in way over their head. Uh there's way too
much involved here. They don't know basic rules. Uh and bring
them up after this video, Ral, since they're timeline wise after
this video of civil procedure, which I understand is probably
your hardest law school class. I don't know, maybe go back and
and and take a refresher on it. I assume like when when he's
like talking down to these lawyers, I assume that judge has to
totally tear these people apart. But I I do agree. Hold on. I
should be clear. I do actually agree with them entirely that
the rules of civil procedure do say that contemporaneously with
the motion to seal and these things being filed he should have
been made aware of the identities like it should have been should
have been unredacted copies to him. Now I didn't realize that
there is another federal rule of civil procedure that says failure
to do so will result in sanction unless there is substantial
reason for the failure to occur. I believe they have provided
substantial reason for that failure to uh follow rules of civil
procedure. I think they've discussed that. I think that is clear
to me that that that seems like reasonable. Um I I get again
we just let the judge decide. The judge will know, but I I don't
think uh I I literally don't think um I don't think they're being
I think it's like fine. I but I'd come down more on Destiny's
side that he should have received the identities as it was filed.
Like I I think that is his right. It it'll just be they're going
to let the judge decide if his rights supersede his previous
conduct in harassing other witnesses and and victims. That's
basically what it's going to come down to, right? And and I think
they're at a point now to where I I legitimately it feels like
it feels like what they're doing is they are grabbing random
people to perjure themselves, but they're telling the people
we'll keep your identity anonymous so everything will be okay
because I mean Vigilance Dream, I'm almost positive they'll be
yelled at by the judge again. But I just don't think that like
people I guess people who are like a part of an online debate
community might think just getting yelled at by the judge means
something for the uh the substance of the case. I I don't see
that. I I just don't see it at all. It's literally just the judge
being like, "Hey, don't do it that way." I I think when they
say we're under significant time pressure, and I'm the judge
and I've heard that excuse before, I feel like from what I got
from the first transcript, if she's going to be like, "Okay,
if I hear this from you again, I will be sanctioning you." It's
actually that you keep saying at the last minute that you have
no time. You I think from from what I read in the first transcript,
I feel like the judge could say that pretty easily. Some of these
people have expressed a great deal of stress and frustration.
And it feels like the stress and frustration has to do with the
fact that they are um they're worried because they didn't know
that they would ever be identifiable.
Uh it takes a lot for them to drop a case or whatever. Zanakali,
it says explicitly in the local rules that based on failure to
follow these procedures, the the the what do you call it the
sealing procedures or whatever that none of the sanctions involved
actually go onto the case or the plaintiff or the the the person
that the lawyers are representing. It doesn't affect the case.
It would only affect the lawyers because they are lying in some
of their declarations. Maybe that's just what it looks like.
For all the reasons more fully set forth in plain motion, it
is critical to protect the identities of these declarants. Then
file a motion with the court and ask for it. You can't just throw
this I didn't see who that was from but thank you dono guy in
the I don't know what the just happened there I am sorry that
that happened with your money so I want to decide this unilaterally
on your own the honor sign council has also explained Mr. Apparently,
the defendant has the full unredactive substantive content of
the declarations. The only redacted portions are those that would
reveal the identities of these. Who am I? Oh, Carlos Perez. That
was uh Pixie's lawyer. That was Goku Latino was the voice right
there of the declarations. The only redacted portions are those
that would reveal the identities of these. Who am I serving discovery
notices to? Who am I asking for uh information or documents from?
Who like also if you bring these people in at the last minute,
we don't even have a chance to reply. Can you wait? Can you not
introduce somebody unless the plaintiff Does the plaintiff in
the complaint have to introduce uh is it an afant to the case?
Can Destiny not introduce an aient to the case? Could he not
say if he was fully confident that Abby um perjured herself or
something? Could he not like actually say I want to subpoena
Aby's like DMs or something for this reason? I would have thought
like that should that should be something you can do. No. What
prevents him from doing that? I actually have no idea what would
possibly prevent him from doing that. Can somebody else inform
me? somebody else who's familiar with the law. I I I'm pretty
sure he could do that. Why is he acting like he couldn't possibly
like introduce them to the case? He's literally out here publicly
arguing that these people are purging themselves to stop that
they're declaring in in um and they're moving for a preliminary
injunction. There could be no legitimate urgency for defendant
to know these witnesses legal identities. That information does
not alter the substantive facts or council's
ability. Thanks for the ammo. I'll dismantle destiny is final.
The vouches is coming. Y estess is coming. Thank you. Carlos
Perez Esquire. I don't know if you donated again or what, but
thank you very much. Defend his client in the proceedings. Carlos
Perez is the name of Pixie's lawyer. By the way, here I'm going to
back it up cuz those those information or documents from who?
Like also, if you bring these people in at the last minute, we
don't even have a chance to reply to stuff that they're declaring
in in um and they're moving for a preliminary injunction. There
could be no legitimate urgency for a defendant to know these
witnesses legal identities. That information does not alter the
substantive facts or council's ability to defend his client in
the proceedings. Excuse me. When these witnesses are alleging
that I've sent them some kind of material, how can I even know
the answer to this question without me knowing who the people
are that are making allegations? Excuse me, what? Or council's
ability to defend his cl. Again, he knows who the people are
who are making the allegations. Maybe he's arguing he doesn't
know one of them, but the core one, by the way, just so we're
clear, the core one that he says he knows is uh is perjuring
themselves is Abby. He knows exactly who that is. Again, um unless
he's saying the other ones, the other ones, I don't even know.
The other ones might not be that relevant. We'll see how they
use them as an argument. Just give me two seconds. I have to
use the bathroom real quick and get some water, Kelly. I'll be
right back. I'm going to back it up just a little bit here. No
problem. Ability to defend his client in the proceedings. Excuse
me. When these witnesses are alleging that I've sent them some
kind of material, how can I even know the answer to this question
without me knowing who the who the people are that are making
allegations, excuse me, what or council's ability to defend his
client in these proceedings. As of now, despite repeated efforts,
the parties have been resolve uh the issue. Accordingly, plaintiff's
updated certificate of conferral is set forth below as follows.
Another thing that these guys haven't responded to that I think
we've raised this issue two or three times. Um, they keep claiming
that I've engaged in the deletion of evidence and the spoilation
of evidence, which by the way, I think is one of their motivating
factors for getting people to tell lies about messages I've sent
them because I do back up all of my messages. I do have archives
of everything that I've deleted. And I can see exactly the messages
that some of the declarants claim to exist that I know for a
fact do not exist on the exact dates and the exact times that
we were communicating with each other. And I don't know if they
think that I am just lying when I say that. But keep in mind
that plaintiff has accused me of deleting evidence over and over
and over again despite never requesting a single document from
me ever. Despite never requesting any of this evidence from me
ever, and despite not seeking any of the proper spoilation remedies
ever. Um, and also they haven't responded to the fact that if
you are telling me that I've engaged in spoliation because I'm
deleting messages on Discord, why don't you account? Wait, wait,
wait, wait, hold on. H how is he saying that they've never requested
a document from him and simultaneously whining to the point of
saying he'll kill himself if they get his Discord records? Can
someone point that one out to me? Hold on. Wait, what? Wait.
Huh? I also don't know why we would trust his own records without
like knowing for sure that they haven't been uh altered, you
know? So, sure, but also if you just know this isn't if you just
know this and you're willing to like uh if you know this and
you've been willing to talk about this case publicly, why aren't
you just saying where where the exact things are? Why why wouldn't
you just go here's where you lied? Look at this log. Why wouldn't
you just do that? He has proof that they lied. Why not just say
this is a lie. This didn't happen. What specific logs on which
specific dates is he is is even being referred to here? Hello.
I I literally have no idea what he could possibly be talking
about, but I would love to know. Yeah, I would love for the messages
that your plaintiff has deleted on Discord because they have
and they've gone back and edited stuff on January 20th, 2 days
before serving me with a preservation of evidence request, which
I would say is a clear demonstration of bad faith. And if they
can't provide me with copies of the conversation from their perspective
beforehand, then I have no idea how the you could accuse me as
bullion when your client is literally doing that. Anyway, okay.
But sorry. Yeah, if Pixie deleted a message, that would probably
be pretty bad. That would probably be pretty annoying. Um, that
shouldn't have happened. Um, there's like so much paperwork.
However, however that message has to be interpreted, I'm sure
it could be interpreted in a negative light in line with the
actual normal rules of the court and everything in the background
for stuff that I have to respond to, stuff that I have to reply
to. It's these huge lists of like demands for um uh admissions
and if I if I don't, then I have to say why I don't or whatever.
and like all of these interogatories. Um it's just so much that's
what I've been doing in my free time at night or in the morning.
It's just a lot of the type plus all the money on the legal representation,
all this. But this is um this is incredibly annoying to me because
for whatever reason, even if I felt agrieved in the beginning
of all this cuz I think that the start of all this was stupid,
you know, whatever the it is very annoying that I feel like now
they're engaging in what I feel is sanctionable behavior, but
what the do I know? Um like this just feels disgusting and gross
and stupid. I don't like it. I don't like it. Stop. I don't I
don't like this. Stop. Stop. I'm sure if you told any of the
women you were sending videos of to other people without consent,
they would have said the same thing. Stop. I don't like that.
Stop. Please stop. What the I don't like. Except they would have
had it like solid ground to stand on. They would have been getting
violated to me. But anyway, there you go. She's actually editing
messages. Um I might even have that in a public filing somewhere.
Yes. Um I think I attached a link of an example of a message
that was uh that was edited 3 months earlier. I think it was
a message in November that was edited on January 20th because
you can see it shows you in Discord when the message was edited.
So it was the day they decided to file that lawsuit or the day
they decided to file me a notice to put a notice for lawsuit.
Shouldn't have done that. Um they began editing messages in their
Discord. So but do you have the money to keep the lawyers all
the way through? I will I I whatever that message was, I don't
think that makes Destiny less culpable for any of these crimes.
It's a good way of saying, "Hey, Pixie, I think you um I guess
if he wanted to like counter sue Pixie or something for for defamation
or like for trying to he if we wanted to file a criminal report
for extortion or something maybe, but um but I I don't understand
how that affects this case necessarily. Spend every single scent
I have keeping my lawyers. I will never ever I'm never settling
anything out like this ever. Um, it's expensive and it's annoying.
Uh, but I mean, I guess I complained before that I'm wealthy
and I have nothing else to spend my money on, so why not on on
good representation? Wow. How much is this whole legal thing
setting you back? Um, I think I've paid I think around 140,000
at this point. So, you know, it's like crashing four new cars
into a into a wall. And I'm glad this guy doesn't know how Well,
actually, no, hold on. Four new cars. Maybe. Maybe. Dude, vehicles
are expensive now. Jesus Christ. I'm glad that I can support
the local economy of California. I'm glad that I can support.
Okay. Struggling lawyers every If Pixie wins this and someone
else sues, I wonder if he will be so set against settling. Yeah,
it'll be interesting to see. Very, Violet. I've Show me a clip
of me doing that. Show me literally any clip of me doing that.
But again, I understand why you're here. You You literally are
just hoping that like Destiny will watch this and see that you're
his strongest soldier and he will fly you out and you can suck
his Okay, probably not gonna happen, but good luck. I approve.
I approve. Okay, I approve of your shamelessness. Good luck.
All the KCAP JC Jtox made is going to be fast gone fast defending
himself when Destiny goes after him. Uh, truth is absolute defense
against defamation. I'm really not concerned.
True.
He can totally go after me for whatever he likes. I'm right here.
He just said he knows exactly who I am. Waste of time. Obviously,
he should be able to sue or do whatever he wants. No, I thought
he had my exact information. Sue me everywhere that I can that
I can send whatever they need. At a certain point, the judge
reacts to their behavior. I'm looking forward to the magistrate
judge going over the preliminary injunction filings and then
until then, I don't know what they actually respond to. But the
Destiny lawyers rock, by the way. Yeah, they're good. They're
good at what they do. But this this case, in my opinion, hasn't
come down to like having incredibly skilled lawyers that are
navigating it in a very like creating an awesome novel legal
theory to navigate the case. It's more just like filing on time,
filing correctly, understanding basic rules of civil procedure,
and being responsive to and making good questions the other side.
Whereas the other side, in my opinion, at this point, is engaging
in in sanctionable behavior, I would say, or illegal behavior,
I guess, but whatever. You've literally claimed that they're
encouraging other people to perjure themselves. Seems uh pretty
aggressive. Anyway, why not fund raise for the legal fees? Um,
I feel like I make too much money to do fundraisers. Just watch
my cake. That's my fundraising. Can't you sue for the legal fees
since this is clearly in bad fa I mean I would hope that if they
if enough of this behavior continues to pile up that I can do
um that I can ask I don't know if it would be like anti- slap
or something but that maybe I would be able to recover some of
that but who knows isn't there some professional duty for a lawyer
to say this type of case outside my area of expertise like I
would expect to see yes but my feeling is I'm pretty sure there
are I'm especially considering how aggressive and stubborn and
um I would say malicious this opposing council is I feel like
they're that's what I thought vigilance dream it seemed ironically
him saying that about the lawyers could be defamation I just
wouldn't sue like the thing about legal cases is they're very
expensive I wouldn't try to defame a lawyer because they don't
have that same like literally if they're at you they can sue
you and they're probably not going to get they're probably going
to be able to file reasonable like motions and stuff and actually
make you pay for legal defense like it's it's not the same calculation
for a lawyer personal relationships um at play here that's what
the feeling is how much research you do on lawyers before you
decided on the ones you chose.
Um, so I I did a lot of research on and then I got a really good
recommendation for an aggressive law firm that was supposed that
was helping me do the case against the actual leaker guy up in
New York. And then when um Pixie decided to threaten the case
and then follow the case against me, I asked them, "Okay, well,
you guys obviously are on the um plaintiff side of this. Who
are the best defendants? Who do you think does really on the
other side?" And um there's a really well-connected New York
law firm. They recommended um Andrew and that law firm in California
who's been exemplary so far. They've been really good idea to
pick the really scummy lawyers. It was the other people's idea.
Ti I had no agency in this decision at all. They're very expensive.
It's going to cost you millions
even stock. I plan to serve you with illegal goblin because you
be goblin
I think that um I seriously doubt I'd be looking at north of
if it ended up going all the way to trial which would be so obnoxious.
My guess is maybe 750k would be my the cap on all the spending
on this which would be a pretty gross amount of um money but
the goal is still to get to it should be gone. Wait, Andrew is
not scummy. He's just good at his job. No, he's scummy. He literally
defends like the most scummy people. I don't hate that he exists.
I don't think it's like completely insane that he exists, but
he is actually scum as well, right? He he is also scum. On his
summary judgement, um, hold on, hold on. I need to make it very
clear. You guys are saying Andrew Breler, two DJs are saying
Andrew Breler is really good at these kinds of cases. What evidence
do you have that Andrew Breler gets favorable outcomes for his
clients in these cases? So, from what I understand, he actually
has pretty bad outcomes a lot of the time for these cases. Am
I Am I wrong on that? I thought he actually got pretty The reason
you get Andrew Breler isn't because you're going to win your
case. It's because you want to wage a public relations battle
and he understands and will prioritize that battle over legal
wins. That's why you get Andrew. It's also kind of dumb to say
bad people need defending, too. This isn't a criminal case. He
can pick who his clients are. This is purely money. Money, money,
money. He'll take anyone that has the money. I think Destiny
himself said he loses more money from bad PR. Yes, that is why
he wants uh that's why he wants Andrew Bettler. That's it's literally
about PR. It's for like rich rich people who have committed some
indiscretion. And by the way, Desi signed an affidavit saying
he did these things, right? Yes. Yes, that happened. He's for
rich people who have committed discretions to make sure their
reputations don't get beat up too much and make sure he can discredit
a lot of the people who are accusing them of things and make
it so in the public eye like it looks about equal. That's the
point of Andrew Breitler. He's not he's not there to win you
the legal case. I have no doubt that he's a good lawyer, too.
The guy probably charges insane amounts of money. But I'm saying
that's not why they got him. They don't get him to win on the
merits of the case. They get him to try to portray the case publicly
and the accusers publicly in the worst light possible. That is
why you get him because the and also it's like a sorry yes people
in civil cases need defending too but there's a significant difference
between people that are appointed a lawyer like in the UK you
just you get appointed a public defender right um if you can't
afford one you get one anyway sure there's a difference between
this and people that opt to choose to do these types of cases
repeatedly over and over and over again it says something about
your moral compass if that is like your client advice. It does
say something about you. Yeah. Uh, vigilance stream. He's acted
with competence and professionalism. Sure. I I don't I think
he's obviously a good attorney, but he's not the level of attorney.
He's not like so good an attorney that they couldn't have gotten
like whoever's good in Florida, right? It's specifically the
PR thing. That is what you hire him for. I'm not saying he's
incompetent either. I'm saying you just don't hire him if you
aren't thinking of a PR battle. That is that is why you get him.
That is what he is known for. Yeah. Also, I don't know why you've
just said you aren't going to go with a public defender when
you have money when we're criticizing the lawyer and the choices
and cases that they take on, not what Destiny does with his money.
Although, the fact that he goes to a scummy lawyer and is trying
to like put that choice off to whoever recommended them to him,
it's just cope. But yeah, I remember this interview. How do you
think the public views your role? I think if you pull every American,
ask them whether everyone is entitled to good legal representation,
95% would say yes. That's uh awesome. Love to see it.
Uh anyway, we aren't even done with the video yet, Kelly. We
got more of the video and we've got his logs and we've got another
video. We've got so much content left, Kelly. Oh my god. Yeah,
I think you can criticize lawyers for this. And I'm not sure
why you're so desperate to not criticize them. I Why are you
so worried that some people might call this guy a scummy lawyer?
because he represents some very scummy people. Yeah, he's he's
he's a scummy lawyer. I don't think he I I don't consider him
evil for being a scummy lawyer. Um I think more questionable
practices where he like malign victims a lot of the time, like
including what did he say? He he is very underhanded with what
he does a lot of the time, but it's fine. Like I don't I don't
think it's evil that he exists. He's literally the victim lawyer,
isn't he? Goes around denying victim attacker, I would say. Tim
attacker. Yeah. Says some very scummy things and has some very
scummy tactics, right? It's not just he represents, it's how
he represents them. Pumpernnickel needs to go for a little while.
Come back tomorrow, Pumpernickel. Sorry. You're trying to start
a You're trying to start an irrelevant argument. I can't have
that right now. Moment. Uh, no. I just He's trying to start an
argument when he knows that that ar he's literally been in a
thousand of those with you and he knows exactly where it's going
and he's trying to do his thing and we're not doing Yeah. Maybe
it didn't start it didn't start out irrelevant because we were
talking about
Uh yeah. Yeah. I'm not saying either of you are saying something.
He's trying to get into an argument over uh how you should critique
people who who defend scummy clients. That's not really the argument
I want to have. No, that's not the argument we were supposed
to be having. Yeah. Well, anyway, we continue on with the video.
The plaintiff has no case. They unless they are willing I mean
I don't want to give them I guess the legal illegal strategy
to just get somebody to blatantly lie all the way to trial and
say no I am going to lie but how does payment work for this?
Do you pay them per each time they have to do something or bulk
at the end every month? I think generally law firms usually initially
you will pay a retainer. Um the retainer will be the something
they'll bill against and then after the ban yog uh Yogi is already
like muted on my exhausted depending on your relationship or
how reliable they think you are they'll just bill you monthly
for cumulatively all your all the services or whatever. So how
does this work if this goes to trial? Can the people giving them
affidavit just refuse to testify? No. The whole point of an affidavit
is that you're saying that you're willing to testify in the case,
right? That's the whole point of of filing these things. You're
also swearing that things you're you're not swearing, sorry,
you are under penalty of pery perjury saying the things that
you've said are true. So, has your lawyer been shocked at how
the other council is acting? Maybe. Yeah. But also, I generally
don't want to say anything about my conversation with my lawyer
because that's privilege information. Privilege meaning it can't
be used in any way, such, shape, or form any of the trials. So,
if I mention anything about my personal conversations with him,
uh it would probably be after the trial. Okay, this is like the
only time I will do this. Okay. Um, the only reason I'm just
covering this is so that there's some perspective of mine out
there because there is so much other bad coverage of this. Um,
actually, I think every law tuber has stopped covering it and
I literally waited like 3 days to cover it. Honestly, it's just
kind of boring. I kind of boring buddy. Um, Amaranth stuff does
way better. Honestly, the amaranth stuff is the people love amaranth.
Okay, the people want to hash ammo. Spies everywhere. Okay, so
I see Jessica and their Discord is all in cope mode right now
obviously. So he's spamming in all caps. This is only about my
one instance of misconduct. Examples of me engaging in this exact
kind of misconduct during the exact same time period victimizing
the same group of people including the plaintiff are not relevant
correct in a including the plaintiff. Uh he's just he's literally
arguing that it wouldn't be relevant if he shared Pixie's video
again. Literally, how does like anything that ends up Okay, preferably
I'd like to see Pixie get some justice, but the fact that he's
wasting all of his money is like perfect for me. That's like
I'm already happy, bro. I don't need to cope because you're already
suffering and that's all I want. It's good. I just I just think
like So, there are legal arguments for why you would have the
other things the other instances of like uh the sharing in here.
I haven't seen Pixie's legal team's argument for it yet, and
they haven't made it before the judge, so I don't want to suggest
what it would be. Okay. Um I do think they should focus in on
certain things, but I don't know. I the way I see it is uh they're
basically doing they're employing some AndyB tactics on their
side too. Okay, it's a little up but when you when you up against
Andy B when in Rome, you know, attack the credibility of other
people how you do it. Okay, how they do it in Rome the way Andy
B does. I'm trying to say they're against Andy B. They're doing
some Andy B tactics of their own. It seems like civil suit. If
you want to have multiple allegations against a person, those
people have to join the civil suit as plaintiffs. You can do
it in a class action where you certify a class. Wait, hold on.
What? Those people have in a civil suit. If you want to have
multiple allegations against a person, those people have to join
the civil suit as plaintiffs. Uh, Pixie is already a plaintiff.
And this will just be another thing that's amended to the complaint.
That's why this guy kind of got. Okay, that's why I said plaintiff
in there, too, because I just wanted to make it unfalsifiable.
But, okay. You can do it in a class action where you certify
a class of people or you can do it in the form of a mass tort
where a bunch of people come forward and make the same claim
with different representation. But yes, welcome to the real world.
It's not a discord chat and it's not a Reddit chat and it's not
a forum. If you want to have people join a suit, they have to
officially join it. You can't just randomly put in uh Redditor
arguments in every filing and say, "What about that and that
and that?" Because those issues haven't been litigated. They
haven't been litigated. They're not before the court. They're
presumptuous of of of my character and other stuff. Like that's
not anybody else's business. I believe this was the same case
for the the DMs that he leaked again of Pixie. I don't believe
that was relevant to the case, but to decide on right now, like
still filed them. Yeah. So, it's inappropriate. It's improper
unless other people want to formally join the lawsuit. But okay.
Anyway, would things be different? Meaning plaintiff would have
a much stronger case if the alleged um actions happened after
the day that law went into effect? Um potentially. I mean, well,
at the very least, the lawsuit would have legs so they could
sue. But the issue is that in my opinion, and this would be I
guess partially for a jury to decide um obviously the internet
has their opinion, but the issue is that what they want to do
is they want to invoke all of the damages that plaintiff has
suffered as a result of not my action, but another party's actions.
And the other party's actions is making this published on a website
like Kiwi Farms, but that other party isn't named anywhere in
the lawsuit. So to hold me accountable for all of those damages
would be incredibly challenging. Yeah, I agree. Holding you responsible
for all of those damages would be the same thing would be probably
difficult. I do think there are like emotional damage arguments
here around punitive damages that will come into play. And certainly
his conduct around how he's talked about Pixie, how he's to blind
Pixie, how he went on Twitter and like directly mocked Pixie
to her face. I'm sure a lot of things like that will probably
actually go in and and work around in in damages as well. damages
aren't just material damages, right? She's suing four punitive
damages on a bunch of these charges. So, we'll see what happens.
I really I I don't think anybody really knows exactly how that'll
go. We'll just have to see. You're dipping into concepts in legality
called Oh, Solus Sloth, thank you for the gifted sub. How far
are we? Hold on. How far are we from the next hour? Maybe I should
shill right now. Should we get the shilling? The shilling? Should
the shilling begin? I think the shilling should begin. Okay,
guys. If you uh if you like the content, I need you to follow
me on every platform. Follow me on X, follow me on Twitch, follow
me on Kick, follow me on everything. Join the Discord.
discord.gg/jsstalkk. Okay, get in the discord so you can join
for different things. You can join colins or whatever the Okay,
I'll probably start doing callins a lot more. I just we don't
really have people who want to argue most of the issues, right?
It just never seems to happen. So, okay, join the Discord if
you want to help the stream go longer. You want to help me monetarily?
You want to help off help save off future homelessness? My future
homelessness in particular. Okay. Oh, Pumpern Nickel just gifted
five and now I feel like I have to un time I'm out. God damn
it. Okay, hold on. I wasn't done. Pumpern nickel. God damn it.
Thank you for the subs, though. I really appreciate it. Okay.
Um, all right. Where was I? Oh, you can. So, if you want to help,
you can give subs on kick. You could sub individually on Kick
if you don't have a gifted sub already. You could gift a pro.
You could give your prime on Twitch. You could give subs on Twitch.
You can do whatever you want. Uh, as far as subs go, you can
donate through Kickbot or Streamlabs. I think I have those links
pinned in both chats. $2 minimum for TCS on Kickbot, $3 minimum
on Streamlabs. There is also, last but not least, the Patreon.
patreon.com/jsdlk. All right,
patreon.com/jlk. There's a couple different tiers, benefits in
the Discord, benefits in terms of pre-stream, poststream content.
I love everybody who signs up for the Patreon. patreon.com/jcl.
Even if you aren't wanting to sign up for one of the paid tiers,
sign up for one of the free tiers. People can actually give subs
on Patreon. If you're signed up for the free tier, you might
get a free Patreon sub. It's possible. So, get on there,
Patreon.com/jstlk. Thank you very much for listening to the show.
Thank you very much to pumpernnickel for the five gifted. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. And we continue on with the stream.
I believe we are hold on 30 and 70. Oh, we're we're there with
the kickbots. With the kickbot donations, we're definitely there.
Okay. Uh we'll go
42602. Oh, two. Boom. Two hours on the stream. There we go. We're
continuing on with the content. We have 10 minutes left on this
video. We got one more video and then we'll go through some of
the coping he did about Abby in Ghat last night, I think, or
the night before. Can't remember exactly. Proximate harm or foreseeability.
So, what you would have to argue is, and you would have to do
this very cleverly. Hold on. making this published on a website
like Kiwi Farms, but that other party isn't named anywhere in
the lawsuit. So to hold me accountable for all of those damages
would be incredibly challenging. You're dipping into concepts
in legality called proximate harm or foreseeability. So, what
you would have to argue is, and you would have to do this very
cleverly and very carefully, you would have to try to argue that
me sending the video to another person, it should have been foreseeable
that that video would leak to somebody would leak to the to the
public at large. But if only Destiny had talked about how totally
unforgivable sharing somebody's revenge or was not revenge was.
And if only Destiny had talked about how repeatedly sharing private
information means it is equivalent to sharing it publicly. Once
you're in a group chat once five people have a piece of information
that information is public. If only he'd said these exact things
multiple times. Oh my god. It's almost like he could have foreseen
sharing Pixie's tapes multiple times would lead to something.
But that would be incredibly difficult because one, you would
have to claim that it was foreseeable for me but not foreseeable
for plaintiff. Number one, and then number two, you would have
to claim that it was foreseeable and I did it knowing that I
would be immensely harmed as well, which is incredibly weird.
Um, and then you would have to argue the proximate harm is mostly
on me despite the fact that the atlarge publishing of the internet
was done by another party. It's just even if the even if they
had that and even if they were to theoretically the other party
wasn't trusted, right? The other party wasn't the person who
was trusted. It was Destiny's violation of trust that that allowed
this to happen. That does make him culpable. Does it make him
culpable for the entire thing? I have no idea. When get like
um you wouldn't call it a conviction, a favorable ruling saying,
"Okay, well, we think that this statute was broken. We do hold
the um defendant accountable." When it comes to calculating damages,
why does he keep making this cheated at two points? Two wrongs
don't make a right. Uh, two wrongs make a right is an illegal
principle. Yeah, it it's again just cope. It's just cope. It's
cope for the public, right, to try to get public coverage of
this in in a favorable way for them. There there's going to be
a big question of like, okay, well, which damages do we calculate?
And that gets very complicated because like I said, I'm not I
haven't published any of this publicly anywhere. You haven't
brought up any of the parties that have published it anywhere.
and plaintiff made a huge tactical mistake of exploding the lawsuit
prior to actually this will never ever be a substantive legal
argument that Pixie publicly talking about her lawsuit is and
and the fact that she was wronged is like her uh victimizing
herself. Pixie didn't even decide to make this public and we
have all the information. Okay, we have President Sunday's conversation
with Nick Doro. As soon as this goes public, we're all we're
all doing videos on it. Yeah, of course we are. Right. the president
Sunday video and the Becket video forced it to go public within
within like hours Doro tweeting everybody tweeting everybody
blowing it up whether or not Pixie made it was public too and
they argue on dates right oh after this date these videos got
way more yeah you're of course Pixie didn't make it public right
Pixie didn't make it public all these other people did filing
anything they didn't file an anonymous lawsuit under a Jane do
under a protective order where they could have filed the entire
thing under seal which would have uh Uh, very violet, you can
join the discord. It's Discord or ban time. Come make your come
make any of your points here if you like. You can join the discord.
You can make any points you like, but sitting in Twitch chat
and trying to snipe is just actually getting annoying and disrupting.
So, come be content on stream or go away. Kept their damage claim
much stronger because obviously if it were to go to court, one
of my counter retorts is going to be and I have Good night. Do
you want to say anything on your way out, Kelly?
No, I was just trying to say bye. That's all. Yeah. Have a good
night. See you. Okay. All right. I'm not joining while KF is
watching. Okay. All the views at time. Hey, look. This video
had 5,000 views after plaintiff made their subtract. This video
has 60,000 views. Um, how can you assign damages to me when the
person publicizing this so much is incurring their own they're
essentially increasing the damage to themsel. And if you look
at all of the underlying case law, it's a new law, right? It's
2023, I think, is when it became active or end of 2022. It's
a new law, so there's not much case law on it. But if you go
through and you read these cases, you're not going to find any
example ever of plaintiffs publicizing their own leaked material
prior to taking Andy the defendants to court. But whatever, you
know, what do I know? I'm I guess. Anyway, uh this is a very
unique case. I don't understand how he could possibly You can't
make the argument that somebody saying, um, I need to fund raise
for my own thing. You're never going to make the argument. You're
never going to make that argument successfully in court. Um,
Carl Jobs tried to make this argument against Billy Mitchell.
Didn't work. Now, that's Australian court, but it just doesn't
work, right? You can't um you can't do a crime to somebody and
then go, "They cried about it loudly. That means they're responsible."
It doesn't work. Jesus. Can you summarize the stuff happening
logistical? Are you going to sue him? Uh they're a Canadian person,
so yeah, sue me. Sue me. Sue me. Sue me. Sue me. I don't even
know. Number one. Um, number two, um, by the way, his entire
pretense for wanting to do this is that he wanted to be sued.
Sorry, he wanted to sue me. Whoops. He wanted to sue me. That's
the entire pretense he had for asking for my information. Instead,
he just tried to dox the person who got revealed. We'll see what
happens. I've already put in a discovery request related to him,
but he was talking about this on his stream yesterday and he
I feel like my feeling is that he knows that there is tom foolery
about because I think he said on stream I think he said that
he was not going to join this unless he had guarantees or assurances
that all of his stuff would be kept redacted and anonymous which
makes me feel like he also knows that there's improper literally
it would be very obvious exactly who I am from the affidavit
that from the not affidavit from the statement I gave to them
be incredibly obvious who I am. And he says he knows who I am.
If I was lying, he could just name me. I don't know. It might
be tricky getting to subpoena somebody in Canada for that same
thing. But it certainly wouldn't be impossible to sue me. Yeah.
I don't I don't know. What is Tom doing? Wait, what are you guys
asking? So, we lose a lawsuit. Do you consider a convicted felon?
No, this is civil stuff. He would just lose a lawsuit. What are
you restricted? Wait, hold on. Did he mention Tom? Did I Did
I totally I just totally missed it. He I feel like my feeling
is that he knows that there is Tom Flurry about anonymous which
makes me feel like he also knows improper stuff going on here.
So we lose a lawsuit. Are you considered a convicted felon? No,
this is civil stuff. You would just lose a lawsuit. What are
you restricted from doing while the case is going on? Nothing.
Well, I mean it's hard to work with people publicly. Although
I guess I'm talking to more people apparently they don't care
that much. But does this firsthand exposure to legal system make
you appreciate the justice system or be frustrated by it? Um,
I mean, I appreciate it. I'm frustrated by opposing council's
behavior, but I feel like they're um I mean, they're just acting
insanely. So, okay. Anyway, will you be able to make a statement
on exactly what you've done wrong after the case, or is there
a good chance that it will be dismissed due to the law in comments?
Everyone still calls you after it? Um, that's on Pac-Man working
with him. Um, I don't know. I don't know. I I I literally don't
know with regards to Pac-Man. I don't know. That's a personal
decision that I'm going to have to decide for myself because
um right now there are a ton. one, there is an incredive there
is an incredibly aggressive and I think personally invested opposing
litigation firm that is like hanging off of every uh I do think
people should email the people he collaborates with and just
let him let them know like hey these are the accusations these
are what he's like cpped to in his affidavit like he he has done
this he's basically used his platform to find women to sleep
with and then shared their videos around I think that should
actually be his reputation I think that should be shared to the
people and you should emailing at two locations where you know
like he's going where you know he's going to be like working
with people. Adam Mockler is somebody he names. I think that
person should be informed. Who else? Adam Mockler. Oh, and Henry
Harry Sison. Harry Sison and Adam Mockler should probably be
updated on this. Now, I wouldn't say send that email out. I think
what we should do is we should probably figure out exactly the
best way to put this information together and then we should
have a like a unified messaging. Okay? We don't want to up in
the way that Dan [__] up with the the Twitch anti-semitism
thing where people are just sending all kinds of crazy all over
the place. I think um I think what we should do is we should
actually like put together something that's effective effective
messaging, right? So they can go and look at it. Well, I'm just
saying you don't want people spamming all kinds of ridiculous.
You just want you want a nice concise way of putting this to
uh to inform people that he's going to partner with or sorry
not partner with but uh collaborate with that he is involved
in this case. He has admitted to sending all these like he admitted
to sending the the nudes or the videos of people um to other
people. What else would there be? The things he's accused of,
I guess. H what else could we put in here? I I'd say probably
anything that's in one of those affidavits could be included,
right? The directing to people to the Kiwi Farms post that had
not only um the videos of him, but but also Pixie's video and
then trying to co to cope and say, "Well, I was talking about
eating. I wasn't actually talking about anyone else." So, even
though the post is the same, um, actually, I wasn't referring
to that. Diddler
destiny.com. Get that 15-year-old quote in there. Oh my god,
what am I supposed to Who put that quote up the other day? I
was like, that's just a direct quote. What are we supposed to
do? Oh, somebody donated it to um to the Amaran stream. Like,
oh my god, these 15year-olds from MLG are so hot. Oh my god,
I can't remember exactly what he said. a single public word that
I say like it wouldn't surprise me if aspects of this um if this
conversation will show up in the next filing, right? So, they
are doing um they're doing uh they're they're just incredibly
aggressive. Uh number one, and then number two, uh it feels like
they're like desperately searching for other plaintiffs. So,
I don't know if somebody else is going to try to file a case
against me using the same law firm or or whatever the else. So,
I yeah, I don't know. We'll see. I don't know. We'll see how
I feel after everything. But Jesus Christ. how often you speak
to your lawyers are available. They're very available. Do you
think Pac-Man is aware? Uh Pac-Man's probably aware. Pac-Man
has like a long relationship with him. I'm sure if Destiny told
him like it's nothing, it'll go away. I I feel like Pac-Man would
give him the benefit of the doubt, which I mean, I guess you
could say that sucks, but I feel like Pac-Man would probably
give him the benefit of the doubt. I speak to them as little
as possible, though, because you get charged for conversations.
If it cost you 140K, how much do you think this is costing her?
She only raised 50K so far. So, one complaint that I would have
about how the court system works
um is that I feel like in a way some of this bad behavior is
a little bit incentivized. I think that opposing council the
feeling I'm getting that it feels the feeling that is being admitted
is that they are working on a contingency basis meaning they
only get paid if if the Okay. Um wait, where is he getting that
feeling from? I actually don't know. Oh, they might be working.
I don't know if they're working on contingency or maybe they
took fees at the beginning and then because maybe there wasn't
fundraising or something. Maybe they work on contingency now.
I have no idea how they'd be operating to tell you the truth.
I would sure hope that at some point they give Pixie a discount
when they keep going, "Ga, we really ran out of time this week
every single time." Seems kind of up. If plaintiff gets paid,
so they're also incentivized in the same bad behavior because
they're basically working on um commission kind of. So that might
also be influencing their behavior. That feels like a very weird
conflict of interest to me, but whatever. Do we have a timeline
on when they would next meet with the judge? No, that's what
I kind of keep pushing for questions about. The next thing will
just be this ruling on the um preliminary injunction. But he
thinks the lawyers are both bad face knowing bad faith, not face
uh knowing they can't win the case and working on contingency.
How does that work? Um bad faith and working on contingency.
And yeah, I I don't Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. Perhaps
he thinks they could just lie about everything and win still.
And I don't understand if they're working on contingency. Like
the only harm to Destiny here is like the lawyer's fees he's
getting. Why would you work on contingency and take a case that
you're having to tell people to perjure themselves in to make
a case that doesn't Yeah, that's just doesn't drive to me at
all. Apparently, there's not necessarily a timeline on that.
So, you know, that cryptic uh pixie tweet was uh or no, I have
no idea. I doubt it's anything related to me. It's probably I
mean I can guess but probably something related to YouTube or
there some project she wants to work on or whatever. Why would
Pixie need to raise money if this case was on contingency? Good
question. Since people are saying publicly and going on streams,
at what point does it become okay to start just leaking? I mean,
you can leak whatever you want. You're you're always fine to
leak whatever you want. The the the only disadvantage there are
disadvantages and there are advantages to leaking or talking
about some stuff publicly. The civil law could be retroactive
or is my understanding flawed? Um, it's I as far as I understand
uh the federal statute that Pixie is suing under is explicitly
is not retroactive. That those laws when they're placed in like
a as federal civil rights to action, I think they're not meant
to be retroactive. So, they would have to explicitly say were
retroactive to this date if that was if that were were to be
the case. You can't just make them retroactive. So, there's arguments
for like how it could become like how the original violation
could still be a violation. I don't know if those would work.
Huh. And that's why Pixie's lawyers filed this seal protection.
You can leak whatever you want. Yeah, pretty much. Like, hey,
I wonder. Hey, you can leak whatever you want. I think I wonder
why the the plaintiff might not trust to just file whatever.
You just leak whatever you want. Leak anything about anything.
It's just up to you to evaluate what you want. The biggest disadvantage
to leaking stuff is that when you're having a conversation with
your um with your lawyer, that stuff is considered privileged
information, meaning it can't be used against you ever or probed
uh in court. So, like, let's say that I'm talking uh well, hold
on. We've forgotten the most important exception to this, which
is criminal behavior. If they're advising you on criminal behavior,
if they're trying to tell you how to commit crimes, you absolutely
pierce privilege. Yeah. To um let's say that I'm talking to my
council. Okay. And let's say that I'm being accused by one side
of stealing $100,000 from their house. And let's say that and
and they're saying like, "I know that you stole 100." Donald
Trump obviously infamous case of this, right? Um because uh because
Luke said that you just bought a new car with cash, so I bet
you stole it or whatever. Something like this. Let's say that
I'm talking to my lawyer. I'm like, "Okay, one thing that I'm
really nervous about, and I don't think um I don't think the
plaintiff even knows this. I was actually at their house on the
day that they said that the cash got stolen. So, I'm kind of
nervous about that, right? But let's say that they never figure
that out or they don't know that or nobody alleges that. That's
fine. But they can't um subpoena or they can't on discovery say,
"I want to know everything you've said to your lawyer." And then
your lawyer says, "Well, just so you know, my client told me
he was at your house on the day the money was stolen." You're
like, "Oh, now I'm right." Because obviously if that was the
case and you could never confer with your lawyer because your
lawyer is really just supposed to be an extension of yourself,
right? So the uh So again, if that guy said if that guy said,
"Uh, hey, I was there and I did take the money." I believe the
lawyer would is the lawyer not compelled in some way to be like
oh you just confessed to me. They have to they can't like how
do they operate at that point? I actually I'm not even going
to say how do they operate at that point? The person just said
I actually did it. I thought the first thing lawyers do is they
say like don't confess to me. I don't want that knowledge. Your
lawyer cannot lie in court. Yeah. They cannot legally deny it
now. Okay. You'll need to future ongoing criminal activity not
pass. Okay. Okay. That would make way more sense to me. Actually,
it would make way more sense to me if it was future or ongoing.
But anyway, keep going. The big one of the big reasons why you
wouldn't want to leak anything is because you're losing some
of your attorney client privilege if you do leak that stuff.
Um, and then there could be other reasons too or not depending
on the case. It just depends. Are these complaints or opinions
about the procedural behavior backed up by your lawyer or just
based on your knowledge? Um, both. I usually have an inkling
and then I ask my lawyer about it and he more or less affirms
but but it's also obvious. Hey, I think this is really bad. Okay.
Well, here's a bill for $500, and I'm going to tell you that
you are a big boy who is very smart, Stevie. You are very smart.
Uh, wait, hold on. I said very smart twice. Here's another bill
for $500. Please go ahead and pay that at the end of the month.
Based on the filings, and it's obvious based on the contention,
and it's obvious based on the um on what the judge was saying,
listening to the TTRO request, that the other side is acting
quite improperly. So, okay, I think last question. Somebody earlier
said why did she follow through with a lawsuit when she could
have had you help her with her personal expenses like school
and surely any lawyer worth their salt would say yeah just do
that. The issue is that the amount of money that she wanted was
at least one or two orders of magnitude higher than anything
I would have ever there's no world where there is a seven figure
payout. Even if I lose the case, even if the jury hits me, like
there's no world where that is ever the pay. Again, the only
time that was like specified was uh was in pre-trial negotiations
and there's no way like if Destiny wants to say that's the number
we believe they actually wanted and they wouldn't move. If he
wants to come out and say that, somebody should ask him. Nobody
really asked him any contentious questions. Like wait, did you
think like you couldn't talk about like a lower number? Was was
she like give me 15 million or else I won't talk to you? I I
don't even know. Pay out. So, one, the request for the payout
was way too high. Number one. Number two, in my opinion, now
there's not like a civil cause for action for any of this, and
I don't know if any of this rises to any kind of whatever afterwards,
I I would say very obviously, I think that um plaintiff was extorting
me or blackmailing me. I think that all the elements of that
crime are very easily and very clearly met. Uh they were trying
to compel me to engage in a didn't isn't that isn't that criminal?
Couldn't you go after her? Couldn't you file a police report?
behavior that I wouldn't have engaged in otherwise by threat
of publishing some sort of private information that would have
been humiliating or detrimental and the in exchange for keeping
that private there's a huge sum of money requested or some other
thing compelled that you would normally do uh because plaintiff
contacted me prior to ever contracting a law firm or anything
I think is very easily it meets all the elements of extortion
or blackmail extortion I think or maybe it's blackmail I don't
remember one I don't even know what the difference uh okay one
of those two but but all I h is that I I think Pixie did contact
him first, but I thought, wasn't somebody like talking about
offering her money? I thought he like talked to Straight about
offering her money or something. Maybe not. Maybe I maybe I have
the time I messed up. I actually don't remember. Oh, they almost
easily there. Um
uh and so Okay. And then also I think that the I think that maybe
they think so one I think that she probably got gassed up from
people saying like, "Oh no, like he's rich and people win millions
and millions of dollars from these lawsuits all the time, so
I bet you know you'll get millions and millions of dollars."
The problem though again and I'll say this if you follow any
of these cases or if you read any of the case or if you just
read the cases that they site um if you go on Pacer and you look
up the cases they site sometimes there are big payouts but dude
the defendants in these sure I think there are mitigating circumstances
here I understand his argument is oh they don't get paid out
that much that or like we could have settled it's like okay I
I'm sorry the the settlement stuff is a negotiation right if
you don't want to negotiate and you would rather do this and
lose a whole bunch of money to go through this whole thing right?
And possibly still lose and have to pay out a large amount of
money again. I guess suits are insane. They're insane men. They're
people who are like spamming explicit videos to their like friends
and family or they're making like six different accounts to post
these videos like on, you know, they're insane defendants. So
the so sometimes just even on some of these crazy cases it's
just like the max statutory payout which is 150k and then sometimes
there's punitive stuff assessed but the punitive stuff assessed
is like for incredibly malicious behavior but maybe a combination
of like reading kiwi farms and a combination of reading everything
else. Maybe Pixie has in her mind like oh my god like he acted
so atrociously and maliciously and like I think this is all intentional
and was like the [__] you're never convincing anyone
of this and it's just [__] Is that alleged in the
complaint? I don't know what's alleging the complaint precisely.
Oh, I don't know. Or he always goes back and refers to the substack.
And then on the last um the last thing is maybe in her mind because
I'm probably going to end up spending a lot more on this um than
what she could have. In his own words said on stream after the
$1 million request or the one million the $15 million request
or whatever they asked me for a more reasonable offer than 100k.
At that point I just said this but now he only wants to cry about
how the original Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. I that's what I thought
I remembered was like he said that they said wait make a more
reasonable offer than I think it was like I think it was like
100 or 50k and like I'll pay your legal fees right but but that's
what they said like make us a more reasonable offer than that
and he was like you it's like dude I you had every opportunity
to settle this asked for maybe I'll just settle with but now
now all anybody ever says any ever says is 15 million 15 million
15 million 15 million her because I'm Um, maybe I'll just settle
because I want to avoid the legal costs. So maybe that was what
she was thinking. But I I would rather I will pay two times more
in legal cost than settling something like this because that
the idea of somebody get if this goes to trial, you're paying
way more than two times like like the easy next 10 or 20 years
on their life by doing some insane unhinged like this. I'm good
on that. But anyway, okay. There you go. Cut. There you go. Oh,
you know what? I just realized Destiny's projection onto me and
Queman is the same onto Pixie, right? He's taking he's basically
I'm sure in his mind he basically blames Pixie for like people
getting doxed or harassed in some way, right? I think that's
what happens here. I think that's the only way he could possibly
have like these opinions. Oh, it's so unsane and unhinged, right?
He must be doing that too to Pixie. By the way, the doxing and
as far as I know, the doxing was all like um before this stuff
popped. Uh there I I haven't checked in a long time on Kiwi Farms
to see what's up there. But um as far as I know that the like
the docs the the like he talks about like his girlfriend issue
that was before. It was like all before. I shouldn't even say
anybody but like I thought um I thought and and him getting swatted
was all before. But he like blames that on people. He like gets
in a time machine and starts blaming it on people in the future.
I don't know why. He's probably in survival mode. I guess so.
Have fun. Uh Carlos and Joanne or whatever. uh listening to this
whole VOD because I know how much you guys love to type up in
your motions and throw them into court papers by listening to
my stream combos. How much you think plaintiff believed the insane
lies on her Substack or still believes? I don't think she believed
any of those. I think she knew all of that was there's no shot
that we're friends for 5 years and then she immediately hardcore
Insta super ultra. Bro, you hold on. You were friends with a
whole bunch of people. You had like relationships with these
people and violated all of their consent. You violated Molina's
consent so many times you had no respect for Molina's privacy.
Anybody who has looked into the actual things you've done is
horrified by the human being you are. There's not a single person
who can look at the things you've done and say you're a good
person. The best they can do is the aerodite thing where they
go, "Oh well, I actually don't think anybody's unredeemable and
as long as he works real hard in the future, maybe he could fix
it." Not that he's put any work in at all, right? Like I I don't
understand how he could possibly Dude, how do you invoke your
friendship? He's doing it again. This is the exact same thing
where he invoked the He's going to invoke the outrage later on
against Abby. Oh, she read my she read my wife's diary and she
took pictures. It's like, dude, you literally sent of your wife
to people without her consent multiple times. You literally leaked
her therapy document to multiple women. Why are you acting like
you're outraged for her privacy? Why are you acting like Pity
is going to use your friendship to to mitigate her her actions
here when you've sent her tape to multiple people? Your friendship
was a falsehood. You're a piece of her rewrites every single
that's just impossible. I don't believe that. Do you think that
she was genuinely or was it an attempt to manipulate you? Um
I mean this is like double hearsay. I don't um in the video of
um again he's going to quote the Aaron thing and Aaron has clarified
this to me and she'll probably clarify it anyway. He doesn't
care about lying repeatedly, but I'll just I'll and last time
missing my guess. He's going to talk about Straighter Raid's
log where Straight Raid said, "Well, if we did a wellness check,
she would just say she's like fine and and she was just doing
it to get attention or something. She was just doing it to get
his attention." Except straight has made it very clear repeatedly
that that's not what she believed legitimately. She believed
Pixie was legitimately and that Pixie, if if a wellness check
was called in, would lie to the people who did the wellness check
and that she knew how to lie to them. She knew how exactly to
lie to them and that was what concerned Aaron. It was like why
aren't you doing a wellness check? Aaron was like I don't think
it would do anything. So I'm like check we're checking in in
person. We're doing all this stuff cuz we're very concerned.
So no it's not weird vigilance stream. It takes a long time for
the police to investigate things like this. Uh you're actually
incredibly just totally wrong about criminal cases not taking
this long to move. Uh for example the Russell Brand case the
the case there took a year from the reporting of the case to
the police actually arresting him and charging him. You're just
totally wrong on this. This is actually a totally normal amount
of time it takes is is actually incredibly normal. Um but it's
fine. Um and it is still a it is still um moving forward. Yes,
from what I understand. Aiming for better. Okay. Okay, dude.
With your advertisements. Get out of here. Get out of here, loser.
Is that all right? Um Oh, it's been like six. True. Wait, that
guy just said six months. It's been It's been three months. It's
been like three and a half months. It's not been that long, bro.
Uh, maybe you could say, hold on. Maybe you could say, uh, five.
You're You're at what? Four four months and four weeks. Four
months and 3 weeks. In the video that was posted on, was it Professor
Sunday? Professor Sunday. President Sunday's channel. Oh, he
knows exactly who President Sunday is. By the way, uh, he he
was totally, you know, the thing that broke him with regards
to President Sunday. It's literally not even uh, President Sunday's
unhinged behavior towards Arrodite. It's literally President
Sunday constantly making fun of his disgusting beard. That's
the funniest thing. That's what actually broke him on Sunday.
It's the beard. It's his beard. It's making fun of his appearance
and how ugly he is. And it's it's funny that he like lets that
through the cracks that he's like actually that vain. You wouldn't
think it the guy who like wants to dress like really badly, but
he is. He's actually incredibly vain. It's very funny. Very interesting.
Oh, wait a second. Oh, wait. Hold on. What is there a link to
like the thing that I published? Wait, I just realized something.
I despite the fact that everybody claims otherwise because people
think I'm legitimately I guess people really do think or some
people I think I don't know if it's my haters or what think I'm
actually insanely arrogant. I do pass by I pass everything I
publish by my lawyers first. Some people like I bet he's I bet
he's stupid enough to think that he's smarter than his lawyers
and does like no I'm not I'm not why would I even risk that a
pretty good assessment of how smart I am. I would never risk
anything that stupid. Um but I just realized I wonder sometimes
I he had on PFP clowning on looks say it ain't so. Uh no I didn't
clown on his looks. I said his beard is disgusting. Wait, hold
on. Somebody sent me a screenshot of the beard. Hold on. This
guy has to come in and say this beard looks good. Okay, I wasn't
commenting on his overall appearance. I said he was very vain
and his beard's gross. That's like that's just facts. I don't
know what you're talking about here. Referencing things that
I put in a first draft of a statement and not the actual thing
that got published. Now, um where is the um I made a public I
made like a when I did like my mini festo. Did I ever link that
publicly anywhere? Oh, wait. Hold on. Okay, hold on one second.
Okay, so the main things that make me wonder, so like for instance,
when Pixie was talking to people that she knew that I was in
contact with. Hold on, hold on, hold on. She was talking to people
that she knew I was in contact with accounts to post these videos
like Riyle, what the [__] Riyle, what these don't
connect smoothly at all. What is your problem? I got statement
and not the actual thing that when I did
uh you're not blocked in every
chat. Yeah, I just think this is like goofy. I just think it's
very goofy. It's very very goofy. But whoever the guy was in
Twitch chat, if you want to argue that this is a very stylish
and awesome beard, you can go ahead. Yeah, it's actually gone
way more now. It it basically the Alipcia is like a group of
Israeli Westbank settlers. Okay. They're unstoppable. They are
unstoppable. They are powered by Yahweh himself. Okay, they will
not stop. They cannot be stopped. They will advance forward until
there is no more hair remaining on this face. Okay, this isn't
even a good picture. Honestly, this isn't even a good picture.
There are way better pictures. I feel like somebody's going to
at me with a way better picture. Hold
on. Uh, hold on, hold on, hold on. I didn't get Hold on, hold
on. Open like this. Yes. One more bonus. Yeah, it like actually
goes under now. Unlucky. Unlucky. Unlucky. Unlucky. Maybe Vigilance
Stream. I don't I think you're incorrect, Vigilant Stream. But
hey, maybe you'll be right. I have a I have a bet on that case.
I believe in it a lot. So, different accounts to post. Maybe
I'm just wrong. Also, Riyle, I'm not done being at you. What
the with these videos? They're not They don't even fit together
smoothly. It's up. It'sed up. Do we see how this one ended?
when Pixie was talking to people that she knew that I was in
contact with that she knew that I was in contact with and then
we go to this one accounts to post these videos like on you know
website they're insane defendants so the so what the bro or they
hold on wait wait wait this is 6 23 down here and this one when
it ends is where is the um I made a public oh it's just like
not quite Hold on we need to go like 3 minutes in or something
I see I I was I was li I was lying on your name, Ry. They they
overlap by a lot. Hold on. What is there a link to like the thing
that I published? Wait, I just I passed everything I published.
I was like, "No, I'm not I'm not Why would I be stupid enough
to pass by? I think I don't know if the first draft of a statement
and not the actual thing that got published." Now, um where is
the u I made a public I made like a One. So, like for instance,
when Pixie was talking to people that she knew that I was in
contact with, she's saying things like, um, this is where I believe
the extortion is like pretty clearly maths on, right? I'm going
to decide my next course of action of what to do with him or
with myself and him based on how the conversation goes with you.
Unless you decide you don't want to talk to him. Basically, I
have my plans and course of action. Pause and we'll choose something
depending on if he agrees he has to make up/repent for the action
and wants to work with me to find a way to do that or if he doesn't
feel that way. I don't want to talk to him myself because I feel
like I tried explaining what blah blah blah little anxious voice
telling me to prepare for the worst. I'll have to start thinking
of more extreme nuclear options to deal with, but I'm trying
to avoid spiraling down. Basically, that and I think the next
part of this Mexican Air Force, I don't know how you find that.
I would have to cover it first. I have not basically saying that
like don't worry, I won't kill myself immediately. I'll wait
for the holidays or whatever. Basically saying like depending
on how my conversation goes with Arerodite um if it's a bad conversation,
she'll kill herself. But the weird thing was, and I don't have
access to these messages firsthand, but I'm sure they'll be produced
in Discovery because that's how this works, right? Were her messages
to Aaron or explain this one right? These are Aaron Aaron's messages
to President Sunday saying Pixie was Yeah. So basically, sorry,
not calling it a wellness check. Aaron said that that this message
does not mean what it's like posted to mean and it was meant
is is posted incredibly disingenuously. It's funny that Destiny
can know that Sunday will say what he has to say to get a message
across, right? Like he will unfortunately I think he will lie
a lot of times. Okay. And I think Aaron has explicitly said when
she says this, she told me this wasn't serious. It was just to
get his attention. Aaron is saying this as in she was lying to
me, not him. Like this was a part of her being terrified that
Pixie was like one bump away from herself. Didn't NS fact check
that or claim otherwise? Yes, she did. NYSE said she did a whole
criteria with Pixie and it was like a high level on the scale.
Like very very real. Vigilance stream. I'm good. I don't need
you to know anything. It's fine. threatening to kill herself
to him, but she told me this wasn't serious. It was just to get
his attention. So, like I said, I've had the feeling that this
has kind of been like a plot since at least December 9th. Yeah,
exactly. This would be like a pretty big conspiracy. And like
I've said before that I generally I don't usually believe in
like big conspiracy stuff without like a lot of evidence cuz
it's just it's it would be pretty except when it's me. Except
when it's it's so funny that he could like realize how insane
he sounds and he like tries to like fix it a little bit but he
can't quite. fantastic for that to happen. But I don't know.
I feel like I've seen a lot of weird and there's like a lot of
connecting stuff that is moving. He's just a Trump supporter.
That's what he seen some weird some weird stuff's going on in
this country. Some weird stuff going on in this country in a
certain direction and yeah, but hey, you know, who knows? We'll
see. The most damning part or I'm sorry, the most damning part
in my opinion is that she was baiting people to talk about the
uh not the tape on Twitter, archiving replies and then deleting
the tweets. Yes, that is very weird. Yeah, but okay. All right,
we're moving on. Good times, fun times. She said she only went
public because the president's video, so that was just a lie.
Yes, that was a total lie. Um, but I show that in my um I think
I showed that in my mini festival video because she claims that
she had to go public as a result of that. But if you see the
leaked messages from um if you see the leaked messages from Aaron,
is it that she was planning to sue or something? She had she
was thinking about suing you for sure, but she her hand was forced,
right? Like she hadn't made up her mind in any direction. You
can see in those messages that I think like 11 days before any
video was published, Pixie already had the entire Substack written
and she was shopping it around for opinions. So, nobody forced
her to go public with that. That's a lie. She just says that
to make it seem like she was forced maybe to defer damages that
nobody said that she was going to uh not publish that. It's just
that as long as she had the option of maybe remaining anonymous,
she was waiting, right? She wasn't pulling the trigger. It was
only after that went public that she published. It's very easy
to just what she would have um acrewed on her own or something.
But why is he pretending that writing the Substack is the same
as publishing it? He's he's like so much more discerning than
this most of the time. It's so funny watching him be just like
actually watching him actually be like the people you criticize.
Are messages in discovery proven to be real without platform
confirmation? Uh I mean you just you take them to be true. um
if somebody's producing a message closest to its original form
and you're just ass if it was like a criminal case, you might
be a lot more um stringent about things. But I mean I think there
are honestly like absolutely in my opinion there are absolutely
ways that you can like there's literally you could just Google
like uh digital record preservation and like sites come up that
help you do digital record preservation and pulling it off of
your devices without anything up. If I submit something someone's
like I don't trust this. it's edited then I mean I guess we can
I don't know what you want to do at that point because any anything
literally can be edited. I can bring a witness to testify that
it's a true or real message if you want but I mean will either
side subpoena Discord. Um yeah that's already been attempted
but the problem is those subpoenas are are disgustingly overreaching
and they're going to need the consent of the other party and
there's no world where I consent to have every single explicit
image and video ever sent or received by my account to the other
party. That's that's disgusting and unhinged. Silence means Okay.
Apparently, this dude is some random small YouTuber who made
this Idubbbz video.
Okay. Wow. Thank you for the gifted sub. Okay, so I think we're
finally The is the song playing. Okay. Uh I think we're finally
done with this. We can go to the next set of DMs that get leaked.
I think that's I think we're going through like the Darius Abby
things. I don't know if I'm going to read through all of the
Darius DMs. I just don't I don't think it's appropriate. I could
I can summarize or we can read through like the relevant one
or something. There's like one that's actually relevant to the
case and stuff and I'll just explain what I think it means and
then we can move forward. We don't need like all of it at all.
Darius, uh yeah, I I feel like 0% bad for Darius getting all
of his like crazy with um his crazy with Zena getting leaked.
Like 0% bad about it now. You know, we should actually go and
get those in in an Imager album. You know, probably make sure
those are preserved. Jesus, a lot of people messaged me beard
pictures. I just opened my Discord. What the How are so many
people ready to provide me with gross beard pictures? You guys,
my senses have been assaulted. It's unreasonable. It's It's crazy.
Thank you guys. Sasuke, that's rough. And apparently, it was
really wellreceived. This guy's got 20. Hold on. We'll see if
there's anything else here. 600,000. I wonder how the pairing
is going to work. The history of all of mankind been a single
person ever to be excited about getting a digital art book. Okay.
All right. Probably true. Physical art books are awesome. Digital
art books are not awesome. Okay. All right. Are we going? Hold
on. I put this in my docket so I wouldn't mess mess stuff up
and misread things. Okay. There's more DG logs from last night.
Is this last night? When the was this? I last night or the night
before? All my timing is messed up right now. My brain is not
working. Okay, so we had more DMs of him talking about stuff.
He obviously said about Abby a couple days ago, like two weeks
ago now. Just about two weeks ago. Got this stuff now. Okay,
so this is from Yeah, I think last night. Hold on. Let me pull
up the Let me pull up the Darius Abby leak and see when it was.
Two days ago. Two. So, not last night, but the night before.
Destiny, here's Darius's leaked DMs with Aby's. What the Who
leaked these? Darius, what does on the phone stand for? On the
phone. On the in this context. On the phone. I don't know who
this guy is and this guy. I feel like these guys talk a lot and
I feel like I would recognize them as DGers. They seem to be
like brand new, but maybe not. A lot of the other names I recognize.
These two names I don't recognize at all. And this guy's always
talking about the case with Destiny. Very interesting. Uh I think
so. I think lawyers told her she would file as Jane Doe, which
she did, but they didn't redact her screen name. So I don't know
if filing is Jane Doe means um to me filing as Jane Doe means
filing a lawsuit. So, you find out here shortly that Abby is
apparently talking about filing a lawsuit. She sent a demand
letter to Destiny. $500,000 settlement is what she asked for
it looks like, which she did follow Jane Doe or this redacted,
but they didn't redact her screen name. Plus, they didn't do
their motion correctly to file under seal. They never disclosed
any of this to us first. I mean, it's contemporaneously at the
same time, but sure, we've we've discussed that to death. The
other council is actually so unqualified to even practice. It's
unreal. Again, I don't think that's true. I'm so curious if they
actually told her to persure herself or if Pixie or someone involved
such behind the scenes told her. So again, this is more conspiratorial
thinking with absolutely zero evidence. I don't understand how
or why this could be the case. Um yeah, I literally don't understand
how or why this could be the case. So, okay. Uh Destiny from
the leaks, it seems like she doesn't want to be part of the lawsuit.
G I think her beer. Okay, she signed on. So, hold on. I'll look
at the I'll look at the Abby DM where she does talk about the
lawsuit. I think it's just this one. Pull this over. I don't
want to go through the whole thing. It's just kind of annoying.
Um, lawyers are very much scaring me right now. And the diary
thing. The documents released yesterday were supposed to be sealed.
I was assured by my lawyer. No, my screen name was on that paperwork,
but I was supposed to be a Jane Doe. So, that statement shouldn't
have been released. I don't know how it did. If anything, it
would help my defense, but I really should be talking publicly
about it. I just wanted to talk to you and maybe Prawn didn't
realize you were alive. So, if he continues to mention me in
DG or any public any public capacity, it will hurt him more.
He won't answer and just settle it with me. I don't even want
anything. I just need his confirmation so I can rescend and sort
of contact my lawyer right now. This is why. So, it to me it
sounds a little bit like maybe she's trying to get a private
settlement or something. She doesn't want to go through like
a public court case or something. You can't rescend an affidavit.
I do not believe.
Um maybe you can. I I thought it's basically Would that not imply
it's not true? I don't know. Maybe you can. I have no idea actually.
I would have thought that like if you if you testify to something
though that it's still evidence. Maybe you could maybe you could
say I misremembered. I don't know. It's it's fine either way.
Um she's got to do what she's got to do. Wasn't Destiny reaching
out to her hardcore? Think he was trying to frontr run a settlement.
Uh so it seems like Destiny was probably trying to reach out
cuz he got a demand letter. It seems like that's what it says
here somewhere here. But he's saying that apparently I or Pixie
or someone told her to persure herself. And he's also suggesting
maybe the lawyers did it, which is just crazy to me. I don't
know why any lawyer like that would be insane. How would this
law practice get as big as it did trying to do this with people
like coaching people to perjure themselves to get settlements
and or to get uh favorable outcomes? I just don't think so. Uh
anyway, so Destiny I and by the way, it's just totally unhinged
to suggest that I tell anybody to pjger themselves. That's [__]
crazy. Uh from the leaks, it seems like she doesn't want to be
part of the lawsuit. G I think. Okay, she signed on. She's an
adult. Should be no issue for you to demand her conversation
on the matter unless she retracts. Damn it. Yeah, but I wonder
if they'll just bring someone else forward to make up another
lie. Abby is so I don't I don't know. I don't know. To me, this
reads like, "Oh, I'm expecting more people to come forward."
That's what it reads like to me, right? Like, why is he just
like, "Oh, I think they're just going to make up more lies to
come forward." Wes has already leaked that Destiny and this person
had a relationship, right? Like that's not doubted.
Um, it seems like she's claiming one of her videos was sent to
people. I don't know again like the whole story there, but to
me it seems very likely that this could have happened and I don't
know why he keeps hypothesizing that there'll be more people.
They'll make up more people to come forward. It's like he's preemptively
dealing with more accusers, right? I don't know. I don't know
that to me. I don't understand the the like cope here of like
I'm constantly being victimized and these people are all lying
about me just given what I know like that I haven't I haven't
compelled anybody to do right given what I know I'm just sitting
here I'm like I like this seems insane to me that this guy's
just making up anyway uh I guess on the bright side if they continue
to act so dishonestly and against proper procedure maybe there's
a world where I can recover some litigation fees on this l W
I don't know why that's l W Destiny why do you think she got
involved to file she seems so remorseful in DMs and like she
had no idea what she was getting into. Uh, the same lawyer representing
Pixie sent me a demand letter for 500K for Abby, saying she was
going to file a suit against me next. So, I'm guessing they promised
her a ton of money or something if she joined as a witness in
Pixie's case and made up a lie to keep that case alive. Again,
why would a like a a highowered law firm be party to any of this?
Why would anybody with like a legal career be party to any of
this? I don't understand. I I literally like if somebody could
explain to me why you would just make these things up, it seems
nuts to me. Yeah. It's like, dude, the storm's coming, guys.
The storm's coming, guys. The storm's coming. What lie did she
tell? Has it ever been proven to be? No. And he's never denied
it. That's the thing. He didn't go, "Oh, I didn't send any videos
of her. That's insane, right?" He's never said that. He's still
He won't deny it. Why not just deny it, bro? Haven't you seen
Suits? I forgot that he's been watching Suits. Okay. Somebody
pointed that out to me and how funny it is. It is very funny
that he's been watching Suits. Okay. He He's He is actually fantasizing
a play of Suits. Okay. He is. Yes. This kind of like this kind
of uh conduct I guess happens in suits. Doesn't really seem to
happen in the real world anywhere near as much. Was she identifiable
in the vids? Like I don't I haven't seen the information that
would point us in any direction on that. Missy Elliot. Anyway,
okay. So, I need to turn my music up. Hold on. Let's go. Okay.
Good. Again, promise her a ton of money or something if she joined
as a witness. The idea that this would have happened, right?
That they would file like a fake case for Abby so that she would
sign on to be a witness for Pixie is just insane as well. That's
like a total another total fantasy. Why shed on their council?
It may lead to them finding a better one. I don't think anyone
else would take this case. Was that before or after they had
her sign the affidavit? It was before. I don't know why everyone
keeps comparing this to Better Call Saul. Saul actually did actually
clever and bet the rule. Oh, another TV show. Another TV show
with legal drama. Oh my god. Let's go. Second TV show. Awesome.
Saul did actually clever and bent the rules or cheated in creative
ways. These people are just stupid and unqualified. Amazing.
Destiny, wait. Wouldn't you usually get a different lawyer in
that situation? Isn't there a conflict of interest in two people
being represented by the same lawyer? They're they're like suing
the same person over the same crime. I mean, maybe if there's
some ways you could develop like a a conflict there, but like
are there any reasonable ones? No. And his uh to the excuse,
what if I settle with one person but not the other? Doesn't that
weaken one case but not the other? How? Huh? Why would settling
weaken the other case? Can someone explain? I I literally I read
these DMs last night with somebody in a in a group call. A couple
people in a group call. Okay. The conspiratorial group call.
All right. Don't talk about it. Don't tell anybody. Many people
in this group call. Okay. And I'm like, can anybody give me a
hypothetical on how settling the case with like Pixie or Abby
would the other person's case up? Oh, also this is at 4:00 a.m.
Yes, it's at 4:00 a.m. Destiny was watching the stream. He is
one of the biggest fans of the stream. I paid for Oiler, but
you won't unttime me cuz Yogi, you have been doing you you keep
doing stuff. You keep doing stuff. You got to learn to control
yourself. Okay. Are you Are you perma on your other account,
though? That sucks. Uh, I'll think about it. I will. I promise
I will actually think about it. Not just a fake. I'll think about
it to make you go away. Um, okay. I'm still I'm just looking
at chat. If anybody can give me like a hypothetical here on on
how this works when you when you settle in one case and it doesn't
and it causes the other case to become weaker. I guess the idea
that conceding confident there isn't enough evidence to prove
the latter. But why would those that wouldn't be relevant to
either to neither case would be like relevant to the other in
terms of the evidence, right? Isn't that the argument he's been
making the whole time that like these cases for other plaintiffs
would have to either be separate or they'd have to be like a
a class action? Why would those cases actually matter to each
other if the evidence for both is like solid? Yeah, settlement
doesn't admit guiltless culpability, but how would that weaken
the other case? I I just don't understand. Are they not testifying
for each other? I don't know. I haven't seen Aby's case isn't
There isn't even a complaint for Aby's case yet. Abby is a witness
to the conduct with regards to Pixie. Maybe if they both relied
on each other. Sure, that could be a thing. Maybe a settlement
would taint the jury pool. Yeah, it would be prejuditial, but
I I literally just trying to think of how that would work. Just
the settling part. I do think there could be a conflict here,
but I just don't. You'd have to say what the conflict is. Seems
like a conflict of interest to represent the both. Destiny, are
you allowed to leak? Dude, Aby's last messages me are so insane.
All these women are actually the most sneaky people in the universe.
It's wild. Here's a picture. So, he leaked Aby's DMs with him
for some reason. I don't I don't know. I don't know. From uh
January. This is on January 1st. Apparently, they talk about
um she talks about how she had to leave or something. Wes was
like making fun of her and then Destiny says, "Hey, I'm literally
being sued going through my roughest PR stint ever, so I can
empathize." All right. I don't want to I hate reading out like
people's private [__] that they didn't leak. I just
I don't By the way, I afforded that same privilege to Destiny
that I didn't really read a bunch of his [__] either.
Basically, Aby's just like, "Yeah, cool. I hung out with them
and yeah, it didn't work." And also um I I think she says I basically
like you like I I like thank you for introducing me to like something
introducing me to a whole new world in life. I don't know what
that means. O it sucks that you don't have anyone IRL who's looking
out for your best internet interest beyond just someone to party
with. Do you think you've overcome most of the substance abuse
stuff now? Thanks. I'm honored. And then she talks about friendships.
She's been two months sober. Well, as much as that sucks, at
least you're healthy and able-bodied. Honestly, this doesn't
mean anything, but Destiny has interpreted this these messages
as like Abby fishing for information on him. He started to put
together a conspiracy where like this is actually Abby trying
to get him to like admit to something. Yeah. So, these people
are the most insane/naky people ever. Hold on. Hold on. Uh where
is it? Here. Yeah. These women, all of these women are actually
the most snaky people in the universe. It's wild. And he posts
those logs. It's actually so unhinged. Do you think the funny
thing here is I wonder if people in DGG don't realize that Aby's
video is not in the there's no Abby video in the original leaks,
right? Like like I don't know. There just see I don't I don't
know why we would just decide that Abby knew about her video
knew about a video here, right? I just I don't understand why
you would think that. They know they Googled it all day and night.
I'm sure. Well, Destiny knows for sure. Destiny knows whose videos
he leaked and it's from a different It's not from there.
Uhoh.
Stinky.
Uhoh. Stinky. Uhoh. Uhoh. Does that mean that Destiny's been
doing this a whole bunch with like other people in other instances
and it wasn't just Rose? Yeah, that's what it means. We all knew
that. We all knew. Oh boy. Oh boy. Now again I will say that
I don't know the underlying I